bien madame la ministre chers collègues
au nom de l'ensemble de mes collègues de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées je
voudrais madame la ministre
en tout premier lieu vous souhaitez une
chaleureuse bienvenue dans cette
commission
c'est votre première audition devant
notre instance depuis votre prise de
fonction le 21 mai dernier et nous
formulons bien évidemment votre
intention des voeux de plein succès dans
votre mission qui est particulièrement
difficile complexe dans des temps
bousculé et sachez que cette commission
votre prédécesseur vous l'a rappelé
souhaite bien évidemment
s'inscrit dans un travail constructif
il y as au sein de cette commission dont
le respect de chacune et de chaque
sensibilité il y à un consensus général
sur l'importance pour nous de faire
rayonner la france avec les moyens
nécessaires et bien évidemment à chaque
fois que ce sera possible nous vous
aiderons pour aller dans ce sens encore
une fois bienvenue j'observe du reste
que nombre d'entre nous ont déjà eu
l'occasion de travailler avec vous le
soin lors de vos précédentes fonctions
se joue en france ou à l'étranger à rome
plus récemment à londres vous étiez
ambassadrice et je pense que nous allons
être particulièrement heureux de pouvoir
engager avec vous ce travail en commun
sur la place et le rôle de la france
dans le monde et son action sur la scène
internationale mais bien évidemment
avant de commencer le vaste tour
d'horizon auquel nous invitons je vais
aborder un sujet
d'actualité puisque
c'est la commission vient de publié ce
matin un rapport sur la réforme du corps
diplomatique qui a été engagée sous le
précédent quinquennat autant dire que
vous n'étiez pas en responsabilité
ministérielle et que ce que nous allons
pouvoir vous dire à ce sujet ne
s'adresse pas directement à vous sauf
que maintenant c'est vous la ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères la
commission a déjà eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur cette réforme que très
globalement et à une très large majorité
nous rejetons dans son principe en effet
nous pensons que cette réforme du corps
diplomatique porte un risque pour la
pérennité de la diplomatie française le
maintien de notre capacité d' influence
il est difficilement compréhensible que
notre outil diplomatique dont
l'expertisé est admiré bien au-delà de
nos frontières et constituer une cible
prioritaire de réformes alors même que
le contexte international se dégrade de
jour en jour et j'y ajouterai que les
positions de la france sont
régulièrement fragilisé c'est pour cette
raison que la commission a désigné les
sénateurs jean pierre grand et andré
vallini pour travailler sur ce thème au
sujet duquel la commission a adopté la
semaine dernière très largement un
rapport d'information que je me suis
permis de vous adresser
nous prenons acte bien évidemment de
votre décision d'organiser une large
concertation sur les métiers de la
diplomatie mais vous conviendrez que les
décisions qui ont été prises ces
derniers mois doivent être remises à
plat et à tout le moins assorti d'un
certain nombre de clarifications et de
garanties qui ont été présentés ce matin
lors d'une conférence de presse par les
rapporteurs ils auront l'occasion d'y
revenir dans quelques instants pour ma
part je suis particulièrement attaché à
l'une de ces recommandations qui est en
quelque sorte une main tendue vers
l'exécutif elle consiste dans le fait de
permettre aux commissions compétentes
des assemblées parlementaires de donner
un avis sur la paire sur les
personnalités pressenties pour exercer
des fonctions diplomatiques d'une
importance toute particulière
cette recommandation s'adresserait bien
évidemment vos envahisseurs du g20 par
exemple en tous les cas des postes
absolument essentiel ainsi que ceux qui
sont exercées dans les grandes
organisations multilatérales
si une telle procédure ne peut
évidemment s'appliquer à l'ensemble de
nos ambassadeurs les responsabilités
exercées par nos ambassadeurs en europe
à pékin et washington où les
représentants permanents dans les
grandes organisations internationales
ont évidemment une importance qui
justifie de recueillir l'avis de la
représentation nationale ça se pratique
dans d'autres pays de manière tout à
fait fluide et à mon sens
7,7 permet cette proposition permettrait
à minima de rassurer nos diplomates et
d'apporter sur ce dossier un élément de
transparence démocratique sans toucher
bien évidemment au pouvoir de nomination
du président de la république car il est
hors de question de revenir sur un
pouvoir constitutionnellement exercer
depuis de longues années est donc bien
évidemment madame la ministre nous
serions très intéressé de connaître
votre position sur à la fois les
éléments que nous avons évoqués dans ce
rapport et ses différentes propositions
en deuxième lieu bien sûr la commission
souhaite vous entendre sur les leçons
que vous tirez sur le plan diplomatique
du déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine
en effet alors que l'union européenne a
déjà adopté six séries de sanctions
contre la russie et que la perspective
d'une guerre longue n'est pas écartée
vous nous direz quel est votre analyse
de la situation sur le plan politique y
at il quelques éléments qui permettent
d'espérer
ou de ne pas désespérer d'obtenir un
jour au moins un cessez le feu pour que
les drames humains que vous avez vous
même constater puisque vous êtes déjà
allés à deux reprises en ukraine pour
qu'il ne se prolonge pas ils ne fassent
pas souffrir inutilement la population
ukrainienne en particulier alors que le
conflit dure depuis bientôt cinq mois
est ce que vous pensez
compte tenu des informations que vous
avez qu'il existe à moyen terme des
perspectives de négociations entre les
belligérants et bien évidemment quel
rôle la diplomatie française entente
elle joué dans ces négociations
enfin au delà de la problématique des
livraisons d'armes à laquelle notre
commission est très attentif puisque
vous savez que nous exerçons aussi les
responsabilités des commissions de la
défense vous nous donnerez des éléments
sur la situation humanitaire dans les
zones touchées par les combats et sur
l'action de la france pour financer et
acheminer une aide d'urgence à ces
populations
après votre prise de parole nous aurons
des échanges avec l'ensemble de nos
collègues qui j'imagine auront des
questions pour préciser nombre de points
j'imagine que certains auront aussi des
questions sur votre appréciation de la
situation chez plusieurs de nos paies de
nos voisins européens y compris dans les
pays où vous avez représenté la france
et plus particulièrement chez notre nos
chers amis britanniques que vous avez
quitté somme toute il y a assez peu de
assez peu de temps je rappelle que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo et qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site du sénat donc selon
là les habitudes de notre commission la
procédure je vous propose de vous
exprimer prendre un quart d'heure vingt
minutes si vous le souhaitez enfin le
temps que vous souhaitez mais pour
laisser le temps après un échange qui
est toujours riche nourris et que votre
prédécesseur estimer au plus haut point
merci madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président avec votre
autorisation je vais enlever mon masque
ce qui sera plus efficace pour vous
remercier monsieur le président a
remercié mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs d'être là et
vous dire que je suis moi aussi
particulièrement heureuse de travailler
avec la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées du sénat
en saluant tout d'abord son président
nous nous sommes déjà vu à quelques
reprises président mais non point dans
cette formation si c'est la deuxième
fois que je m'exprime au sénat depuis
que le président de la république et la
première ministre m'ont accordé leur
confiance et j'aurais réaffirmé devant
cette commission ce que j'ai pu dire
dans l'hémicycle
comme mon prédécesseur j'aurai à coeur
d'entretenir avec vous la relation de
travail de la plus fluide et la
meilleure possible je vous tiendrai
naturellement régulièrement informé des
derniers développements sur les dossiers
prioritaires de politique étrangère et
je suis prête bien sûr à débattre avec
vous autant que nécessaire et à vous
rendre compte d'une façon générale bien
sûr de notre action diplomatique
16 et ceux d'entre vous qui me
connaissent je faisais allusion à m'en
passer monsieur le président
savent que je n'ai qu'une ambition agir
au service de la france et des français
et ce sera le cas dans ses nouvelles
fonctions je serai je l'espère une
interlocutrice ouverte à l'écouté est
toujours disposée au dialogue alors je
me réjouis de trouver ou de retrouver en
vous des interlocuteurs expérimenté des
interlocuteurs exigeant que je sais est
extrêmement attentif à l'actualité
internationale mais aussi à l'actualité
du ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères particulièrement vigilant en
particulier quant aux moyens dont
dispose ce ministère et à l'exécution de
son budget nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir
j'en viens maintenant si vous me le
permettez comme vous m'avez invité à
quelques sujets que je voudrais aborder
avec vous à titre liminaire d'abord la
guerre en ukraine qui domine encore
largement l'agenda international
mais aussi notre agenda intérieur par
ses répercussions de tous ordres avant
de revenir sur quelques sujets
importants du moment où il y en aurait
beaucoup mais je voudrais prendre
quelques instants pour parler du sahel
et de l'iran si vous le permettez avant
de revenir sur les situations du
ministère
l'ukraine tout d'abord
la guerre
d'agressions dans la russie s'est rendu
coupable un contre l'ukraine domine
largement notre agenda la russie a fait
le choix de ramener la guerre sur le
continent européen
en violant brutalement le droit
international en rompant l'ensemble de
ses propres engagements elle met
délibérément en cause les principes qui
régissent notre architecture de sécurité
collective depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est une violation des
principes de la charte des nations unies
des principes fondamentaux du droit
international et également du droit
international humanitaire qui se déroule
sous nos yeux depuis le 24 février
il n'y a pas je dois le dire il n'y a
pas de justification possible aux
agissements dont la russie je le dis
clairement et seul coupable est seule
responsable
notre approche sur le sujet a toujours
été clair nous voulons mettre fin au
conflit sans devenir belligérants et
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis le
24 février nous avons consenti des
efforts majeurs pour aider l'ukraine
pour l'aider à se défendre pour l'aider
à recouvrer sa souveraineté
alors qu'elle est depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant face à l'invasion russe je
voudrais rappeler les quatre piliers de
notre engagement
le premier c'est fournir à l'ukraine un
soutien politique diplomatique
humanitaire économique et financier
manifester notre solidarité aux
autorités comme au peuple ukrainien et
cela représente vous le savez mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
un effort considérable à titre national
pour notre pays puisque nous en sommes
d'ores et déjà à 2 milliards d'euros
d'efforts nationale s'y ajoutent du côté
de l'union européenne l'union européenne
à laquelle nous contribuions une
assistance qui se montrent d'ores et
déjà également à 9 milliards d'euros
dont un déjà engagés nous avons aussi
participé parce qu'il faudra penser à
l'avenir à la confiance de lugano début
juillet le 5 juillet conférence qui a
permis de lancer une coordination entre
partenaires et de poser quelques
grands principes qui devront régir la
reconstruction de l'ukraine la france et
je veux citer la non seulement l'état
mais les collectivités locales
concentrera ses efforts le moment venu
sur la région de churchill yves avec
laquelle les liens sont anciens
le soutien à l'ukraine cela se traduit
également vous l'avez en tête mais je
veux le rappeler par cette décision
historique qui a été prise à l'unanimité
des 27 au conseil européen des 23 et 24
juin d'accorder le statut de pays
candidat à l'ukraine et à la moldavie
c'est une décision qui était
exceptionnel le chef de l'état l'a bien
dit à circonstance exceptionnelle
décision exceptionnelle
une décision qui était nécessaire pour
les peuples ukrainien et moldaves et une
décision nécessaire aussi je veux le
souligner pour notre propre sécurité
comme pour la stabilité du continent
européen
l'urgence commande d'arrimer ces pays à
l'europe sans attendre l'aboutissement
du processus d'adhésion qui ne dérogera
pas aux règles habituelles n'y aura pas
de processus accéléré les critères
classiques devront être remplies et donc
nous voulons qu'il n'y ait pas de temps
d'attentes qu'il n'y ait pas de vide et
pensons engager dès à présent des
coopérations concrètes dans un certain
nombre de domaines on cite souvent
l'énergie des infrastructures
mais aussi la mobilité des jeunes
d'autres sujets peut-être dans le cadre
de cette initiative qui a été prise par
la france qui a été reprise par l'union
européenne et qui est celle de la
communauté politique européenne
s'adressant donc à l'ensemble des pays
européens par la géographie donc pas au
sens union européenne pays européens qui
candidat au nom candidats partagent les
mêmes valeurs démocratiques
une première réunion se tiendra sous
présidence tchèque qui a suivi la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
a prague au mois d'octobre
le deuxième pilier de notre action c'est
apporter à l'ukraine un soutien matériel
et en particulier un soutien militaire
en lui fournissant les équipements y
compris des équipements les taux qui lui
permettent de se défendre qui lui
permettent de continuer à résister voire
de reprendre du terrain
j'étais hier à bruxelles pour un conseil
affaires étrangères avec mes homologues
européens donc et nous avons pris à ce
titre une décision importante qui est
d'augmenter la facilité européenne de
paix qu'est l'instrument qui permet
de soutenir cet effort d'une nouvelle
tranche donc de 500 millions d'euros
pour aider les ukrainiens à tenir ce qui
porte à deux milliards et demi d'euros
l'assistance militaire de l'union
européenne en soutien à l'ukraine ce
pays a besoin de nous nous avons besoin
qu'ils tiennent et donc nous répondons
présents à titre national la france
prend toute sa part à cet effort
collectif
même si nous soulignons moins que
d'autres ce que nous faisons pour des
raisons que chacun peut comprendre nous
avons fait le choix de ne pas
communiquer sur la totalité de notre
contribution militaire et certainement
pas de la détailler ce sont des
informations dont tous les camps n'ont
pas besoin et que nous réservons à nos
partenaires européens alliés et surtout
à notre partenaire ukrainien chacun a en
tête par exemple les 12 canons caesar
255 d'ores et déjà livré et les six
autres dont le président de la
république a annoncé à kiev le 16 juin
la livraison prochaine et qui sont en
route je peux vous le dire ce n'est
qu'une illustration encore une fois nous
faisons beaucoup d'autres choses sur le
plan militaire
troisième pilier de l'action de la
france assurer une condamnation la plus
large possible au plan international des
agissements russe nous l'avons fait tout
de suite et nous avons déployé des
efforts considérables pour que aux
nations unies grâce de vote l'assemblée
générale des nations unies
l'agression bien aussi soit condamnée
par une très large majorité des états
membres de l'onu ce sont aussi les
efforts que nous déployons en soutien à
la cour pénale internationale
car il ne saurait y avoir d'impunité
pour les criminels de guerre et par
ailleurs est un complément de tout cela
l'union européenne et 43 pays bien sûr
donc la france un parmi ces pays ont
exprimé dans une déclaration le 13
juillet leur plein soutien aux démarches
engagées par l'ukraine devant la cour
internationale de justice autres voies
de droit contre l'agression menée par la
russie
quatrième pilier faire comprendre à la
russie qu'elle a choisi une impasse mais
aussi asphyxier progressivement le
financement son effort de guerre ce sont
les mesures restrictives on appelle plus
communément sanctions et qui sont des
sanctions particulièrement massives sans
précédent je dois le dire qu'ils sont
mises en oeuvre depuis le début février
quarante huit heures après le
déclenchement de l'agression les
premières sanctions européennes ont été
adoptés nous avons adopté 6 e +1 devrait
agir cette même sur le baptise pas ainsi
paquet de sanctions avec nos partenaires
européens et avec nos alliés nous avons
renforcé ses sanctions encore hier en
adoptant
une interdiction
d'importation d'or en provenance de
russie ce qui va priver la russie de
plusieurs milliards d'euros de revenus
par an en réalité c'est presque 20
milliards d'exportations que la russie
faisait vers le reste du monde ça n'est
donc pas une sanction mineure nous avons
aussi et ça c'est l'application d'une
décision qui avait été présent angers7
nous avons aussi toujours dans le droit
fil de ce qui avait été décidé par les
chefs d'état ou de gouvernement g7
renforcé des sanctions individuelles
pris des mesures restrictives
complémentaire contre un certain nombre
d'individus cinquante cinq individus de
plus ont été ciblés hier
de plus et toujours à 27 est toujours
hier nous avons
renforcé les dispositifs européens
permettant de mieux lutter contre le
contournement des sanctions certains des
as membre n'applique certains états
pardon non membre n'applique pas les
sanctions mais on a observé aussi par
ailleurs certains contournement des
sanctions et donc il fallait il mettre
un terme tout ceci sera effectif après
l'accord politique obtenu hier dès cette
semaine sans doute dès demain par une
décision juridique formalisée au coreper
dont le message est clair nous luttons
contre tous ceux qui participent à
l'effort de guerre contre l'ukraine
alors vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président notre indépendance et donc
notre sécurité à 1 go nous ne devons
pour autant céder devant aucun chantage
et au contraire nous mobilisons tous les
leviers pour priver vladimir poutine de
larmes énergétique ça exige au plan
national que nous fassions des efforts
de sobriété supplémentaires le
gouvernement en a déjà parlé il
souhaitera
donner l'exemple à ce titre le prénom de
la république longuement précisé le 14
juillet ça suppose aussi que nous
réduisions encore la part des
hydrocarbures dans notre bouquet
énergétique au profit du nucléaire au
profit des énergies renouvelables mais
aussi suppose que nous continuions à
diversifier notre approvisionnement en
pétrole et en gaz comme nous le faisons
et enfin nous avons par ailleurs un un
dialogue avec les pays producteurs de
pétrole et de gaz pour les inciter à
produire davantage faute de quoi il
ferait le jeu de moscou
deuxième point nous devons face à ce
défi et ce défi lancé collectivement à
l'europe renforcer notre sécurité
collective
à cet égard nous avons obtenu plusieurs
avancées concrètes particulièrement
importante au moment du sommet de l'otan
à madrid fin juin je sais que vous avez
entendu tout récemment notre
représentante permanente auprès de
l'organisation de l'atlantique nord
marianne domenach vous a présenté ses
avances et donc je serais bref sur ce
point d'autant que nous aurons un nouvel
échange dès jeudi je crois dans
l'hémicycle puisque vous aurez à vous
prononcer sur le projet de loi
autorisant la ratification des deux
protocoles d'adhésion de la suède et de
la finlande l alliance atlantique mais
permettez-moi souligné l'importance
politique de ces adhésions quand tu
étais là aussi
manifester au moment du sommet de madrid
cela va renforcer notre sécurité
collective va renforcer aussi notre
posture au sein de l'espace baltique et
renforcer enfin je veux le souligner je
ne manque jamais de le souligner
la place des européens au sein de
l'alliance atlantique puisque nous
aurons si le parlement approuve deux
états européens de plus au sein de
l'alliance ce sont donc deux bonnes
nouvelles bonne nouvelle pour l'europe
bonne nouvelle aussi pour notre temps et
notre sécurité collective et donc pour
la sécurité des français
dernier volet enfin notre réponse à
l'agression parce que cette crise prend
plusieurs formes et touche plusieurs
secteurs je vous évoquez la sécurité
alimentaire pendant des décennies depuis
les années 2000 depuis les objectifs de
développement du millénaire nous avons
réussi collectivement à faire régresser
le nombre de pauvres dans le monde et
faire régresser la faim dans le monde
malheureusement
nous observons une rupture avec cette
tendance et les chiffres de la faim dans
le monde se dégrade désormais et se
dégrade notamment parce que la russie
applique en ukraine une stratégie dont
le cynisme est totale et qui n'est
exposé au risque d'une crise alimentaire
croissante touchant de nombreux pays
dans le monde blocus de la mer noire
destruction des infrastructures
agricoles
ukrainienne en un mot
instrumentalisation d'une potentielle
famine et avec nos partenaires européens
et internationaux à l'onu à l'om c'est
et où j'essaie tout se mobiliser une
manoeuvre est en cours peut-être
aboutira-t-elle demain mais nous sommes
encore circonspects sous les auspices
des nations unies pour trouver un accord
entre eux nations unies russie ukraine
turquie afin de trouver des solutions
pour reprendre l'exportation des
céréales wierre la mer noire sachant que
les exportations de céréales existe par
le continent par voie routière
ferroviaire ou fluvial mais ils ne
suffisent pas emporté les quantités qui
serait nécessaire donc nous verrons si
cela peut aboutir et se concrétiser
demain je reste prudente tant nous avons
vu ces dernières semaines la russie
ajoutez quelques conditions chaque fois
que une étape était franchie et puis je
vous rappeler à ce titre que nous avons
mis à profit notre présidence du conseil
de l'union européenne pour lancer entre
européens une initiative qui est la
mission pour la résilience alimentaires
et agricoles mieux connue sous son
acronyme en anglais pharma qui vise à
relever trois défis donc cette
initiative est reprise désormais par
l'union européenne pour relever trois
défis la libre circulation des denrées
ce qui requiert la transparence des
marchés agricoles et l'interdiction la
prohibition de toute restrictions aux
exportations on avait vu certains pays
adopter des mesures restrictives nous
sommes passés par le canal de l'om c'est
pour avancer
deuxièmement la solidarité renforcée
envers les pays les plus vulnérables
nous passons par le pam pour les aider
davantage et le président de la
république a pu annoncer vous vous en
souvenez le doublement de la
contribution de la france au programme
alimentaire mondial et troisième pilier
l'accroissement des capacités de
production agricole et alimentaire dans
les pays du sud des productions qui
doivent être plus durable et plus
résiliente notamment bien sûr en afrique
nous nous appuyons pour cela sur le fida
et enfin sur ce volet parce que nous
avons voulu et réussit à le mobiliser le
secteur privé peut et doit aussi
apporter sa contribution cet effort de
solidarité
nous avons réuni avec marc fesneau
ministre de l'agriculture donc sous
l'égide de la france 17 entreprises qui
ne sont pas uniquement des entreprises
françaises mais aussi des entreprises
africaines européennes
ou internationales qui représentait
l'immense majorité du secteur du négoce
pour que elles forment elles l'ont fait
donc le 23 juin une coalition mondiale
du secteur privé pour la sécurité
alimentaire qui va aborder sa propre
contribution concrète par la fourniture
des espaces de stockage par la
fourniture de matériel roulant toute une
série de dispositifs
qui sont mieux à même que les états
d'apporter avec comme point d'étape un
rendez vous qui a d'ores et déjà été
fixé en septembre en marge de la
prochaine assemblée générale des nations
unies c'est une action complément de
celles des états qui est forte utile
je veux évoquer brièvement la situation
en afrique et
particulièrement au sahel parce que je
reviens d'un déplacement effectué au
niger avec le ministre désormais nous
avons effectué ce déplacement sébastien
lecornu et et moi même à la demande du
président de la république
au niger pour discuter avec les
autorités de ce pays de nos coopérations
futures dans tous les domaines et pas
seulement dans le domaine de la sécurité
de la défense puisque notre coopération
ne ne doit pas avoir ce seul visage mais
avoir aussi le visage du partenariat que
nous appelons de nos voeux de l'aide au
développement de la formation
d'éducation et de l'aide humanitaire
j'ai d'ailleurs pu signer quelques
accords à ce titre et j'en ai été forte
heureuse en un mot et pour informer
votre commission il était frappant de
constater que nos homologues nigérien et
en particulier
leur président le présent bazoum se sont
montrés très inquiet pour la sécurité de
leur pays
surtout après le retrait de barkan du
mali mais nous ne pouvions plus rester
mais pas seulement pas seulement les
menaces sont nombreuses sur plusieurs de
leurs frontières ils nous ont donc
demandé de rester engagés militairement
alors que tu ais je veux rappeler que
l'opération
qui contribuent sous l'autorité sous le
commandement des forces armées
nigériennes à chasser les groupes
terroristes armés s'effectue bien sous
le commandement des forces nigériennes
suite l'expression des besoins que nous
avons entendu la semaine dernière nous
allons établir une feuille de route et
définir mieux les modalités de notre
partenariat dans les semaines qui
viennent l'objectif vous l'avez
peut-être vu et de pouvoir aboutir en
septembre une feuille de route agréé par
les uns et les autres que nous
présenterions à nos plus hautes
autorités à ce moment là nous cherchons
associé aussi nos partenaires européens
les autorités du niger en forme et
publiquement le voeu que quelques pays
européens puissent poursuivre la région
certains d'entre eux sont déjà présents
pour de la formation mais au delà de la
formation pour contribuer à ce que nous
essayons de faire ensemble et après
avoir évoqué très brièvement le niger je
voudrais revenir sur la situation au
mali puis ce que j'évoquais le lard et
articulations de notre dispositif le
président de la république vous savez a
dû décider au mois de février il l'a
fait en accord avec nos partenaires
européens et en accord avec nos
partenaires africains a dû décider de
retirer nos forces nous étions présents
au mali à la demande des autorités du
mali dès lors que les nouvelles
autorités issues d'un double coup d'état
ne souhaitait plus la présence française
et il fallait en tenir compte
retirer nos forces ce retrait est en
cours il se déroule convenablement il se
déroule selon le calendrier prévu je
veux dire par là que nous devrions avoir
achevé à la fin de l'été c'est un choix
bien sûr qui marque un tournant qui aura
des conséquences
mais je veux ajouter que pour autant
nous n'avons pas abandonné notre action
au sahel je parlais du niger mais y
aurait d'autres exemples et pour ce qui
concerne le mali nous maintenons notre
pression nous avons suspendu tous nos
financements tous les financements qui
transitent par les autorités maliennes
ont été suspendus seuls les financements
humanitaire qui vont directement à des
projets de développement et dont nous
sommes certains qu'ils bénéficient
exclusivement aux populations à ce
projet ont été maintenues
la plupart des bailleurs internationaux
d'ailleurs ont fait de même il y avait
trop de détournement et donc il fallait
recentrer tout notre aide nous l'avons
fait le dernier élément sur ce difficile
dossier et que le 3 juillet
l'organisation régionale qui la cedeao a
décidé à la fois d'un calendrier de la
transition pour le retour vers des
élections et d'une levée partielle des
sanctions
le mali reste exclue de l'organisation
des engagements ont été pris dont il
faudra que les membres de la cdo
vérifier qu'ils sont bien tenues étape
par étape comme prévu dans leurs accords
et les sanctions économiques et
financières commerciales
si elles ont été levées ne signifie pas
que toutes les sanctions des partenaires
africains du mali ont été levées les
sanctions individuelles demeurent elle
vise 150 personnalités et bien sûr cible
essentiellement la junte et je rappelle
évidemment ça va de soi que la france et
l'union européenne ont pour leur part
maintenus les sanctions qui avait été
adoptée après les coups d'état au-delà
de ça vous avez entendu le président de
la république vous avez entendu madame
la première ministre pendant sa
déclaration de politique générale la
france souhaite renouveler en profondeur
sa relation à l'afrique notamment en
s'adressant désormais davantage à la
jeunesse africaine en s'empressant
davantage aux sociétés civiles dans le
droit fil
de la politique qui avait exposé
présenté exposé en détail le président
de la république dans son discours de
ouagadougou de 2017 mais aussi dans ce
que nous avons fait avec la société
civile africaine lors du sommet afrique
france de montpellier
en 2021 et à ce titre nous travaillons à
deux chantiers concrets en particulier
je veux citer une maison des mondes
africains
en france qui sera un lieu de référence
pour la création contemporaine un musée
que nous ambitionnons veut fermer un
lieu de création et puis un fonds
d'innovation pour la démocratie pour
soutenir des projets concrets pour
soutenir la recherche
aussi dans ce domaine sur le continent
africain
je termine en rappelant que nous ne
sommes pas seuls à nous soucier de
des différentes situations difficiles
qui se présentent en afrique et de la
situation de l'afrique en règle générale
nous avons convaincu nos partenaires
européens de la nécessité de s'impliquer
car il en va bien évidemment aussi de la
sécurité
d autres pays européens et pas seulement
de la france nous avons pu sous notre
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
en février dernier réunir un sommet
union européenne union africaine c'était
une étape importante de la refondation
et de l'européanisation si je puis dire
de ce partenariat de continent à
continent qui me semble indispensable
dans tous les domaines et pas seulement
dans le domaine de la sécurité
quelques mots sur l'iran sans trop
prolongé ses propos liminaires monsieur
le président parce que la situation est
extrêmement grave
également et parce que le temps est
compté
pour résumer à un dossier qui dure
depuis de très longues années
et des négociations qui durent depuis de
très longues années également un accord
avait pratiquement été conclu entre
négociateurs au mois de mars dernier et
donc sur la table c'est ce qu'on appelle
le l'accord qui permettrait le retour au
jeep is you et
qui est le résultat de très longues et
difficiles négociations
d'année en réalité d'efforts
diplomatiques avec nos partenaires du p3
et avec l'union européenne
nous avons été motivée par une
conviction forte qui que l'accession de
l'iran
au nucléaire militaire crée évidemment
une véritable crise régional des pays de
la région avec lesquels nous entretenons
ce particulièrement inquiet de cette
perspective mais ça mettrait aussi en
danger le régime de non prolifération
dans le monde et accroître et
vraisemblablement aussi le risque d'un
potentiel conflit nucléaire toutes
choses que nous ne devons pas voir
arriver
al'inverse le retour de l'iran jpy sio
et permettrait à ce pays de sortir de l'
isolement politique mais aussi des
éléments économiques avec un mécanisme
de levée progressive et contrôlée des
sanctions et répondre et j'en suis
convaincu également aux aspirations de
la population iranienne qui ne trouvent
pas toujours à s'exprimer puisque les
processus de décision
sont particulièrement opaques dans ce
pays ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que nous sommes près du moment où il n'y
aura plus de retour en arrière possible
nous avons fait beaucoup d'efforts nous
avons fait preuve d'une très grande
patience mais la situation actuelle
n'est plus tenable
l'iran multiplie les processus
dilatoires et on connaît son talent à le
faire il poursuit le démantèlement des
dispositifs de suivi de la ya donc les
activités nucléaires de l'iran ne sont
plus contrôlés comme elle devrait l'être
et donc nous n'avons pas les
vérifications qui devrait être faite
tout récemment au mois de juin nous
avions réussi à ré engager des
négociations
certes indirecte mais des négociations
entre iraniens et américains
négociations qui se sont tenues à dos et
qui ont été malheureusement marquée par
un recul dans les positions iraniennes
qui demande une série de choses
nouvelles et parallèlement à tout ça
parallèlement le programme nucléaire
iranien continue de se développer
c'est une situation grave un accord
permettrait de retarder il ne serait pas
miraculeux sans doute et ne résoudrait
pas tous les problèmes régionaux mais il
permettrait de retarder de retarder
significativement
le franchissement par les rangs du seuil
nucléaire qui serait gravissime
le jpy seo et conserve un intérêt
chaque jour un peu moins pourrait-on
dire puisque l'iran poursuit ses progrès
et se rapproche du seuil nucléaire mais
nous sommes convaincus qu'il y à un
espace qui reste ouvert pour peu de
temps et nous disons à l'iran je les
fais moi-même auprès de mon collègue
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
république islamique d'iran que le temps
est compté nous lui disons qu'il n'y
aura pas de meilleurs accords sur la
table aucun autre accord ne sera
négociée chacun peut comprendre par
ailleurs que les perspectives des
élections de mi mandat aux états unis
d'amérique ne permettront pas aux états
unis de faire d'autres pas quand bien
même il le voudrait donc le messager est
simple l'iran ferait une grave erreur en
pensant qu'il pourra obtenir un meilleur
accord ça n'est pas le cas et s'il
attendait il n'y aura tout simplement
plus d'accord sur la table
je vous évoquez monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
puisque vous l'avez fait président mais
j'y reviendrai certainement plus en
détail dans les questions la situation
qui est celle du ministère de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères
vous avez consacré de récents travaux
vous avez consacré une conférence de
presse ce matin
alors vous le savez et ce n'est pas un
événement banal parce que je crois que
notre maison n'est pas coutumière des
mouvements de grève c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire le quai d'orsay a connu un
mouvement de grève le 2 juin dernier
c'est une mobilisation qui est
inhabituel dont je mesure toute la
portée et donc au delà de moi le
gouvernement mesure toute la portée elle
est évidemment
révélatrices d'un malaise et de mèze qui
touche notre administration centrale
comme nos postes à l'étranger mais
révélatrice
je le crois profondément au delà de ce
malaise
d'un décalage croissant au fil des
années
dirais-je même au fil des dizaines
d'années qui ont vu l'émission
confiait ce ministère être toujours plus
nombreuses parce qu'un certain nombre de
questions globales n'existait pas tout
simplement une génération parce que nous
ne nous occupons pas de la pandémie
comme nous l'avons fait depuis deux ans
parce que les négociations climatiques
ont pris de l'importance parce que le
thème de la biodiversité n'a été
introduit que récemment dans la vie
internationale sous l'égide de la france
d'ailleurs donc les missions sont sans
cesse croissante les besoins de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger demeure et
face à cela les moyens budgétaires les
moyens humains jusqu'au coup d'arrêt que
grâce à la représentation nationale mon
prédécesseur jean yves le drian et je
veux à la fois remercier la
représentation nationale et rendre
hommage à jean yves le drian permet de
donner un coup d'arrêt mais un coup
d'arrêt qui ne permet pas de remonter ce
que nous avions perdu au fil des années
si cela je pense le sens du mouvement
les agents de ce ministère en ministère
auquel j'ai consacré l'essentiel de ma
vie professionnelle auquel j'étais vous
l'essentiel de mon activité
plus qu'à plein temps depuis maintenant
deux mois ce sont des agents qui ont le
sens du service public ils l'ont
chevillée au corps c'est un engagement
que de servir le mystère de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères ils l'ont montré
d'ailleurs ils ont montré depuis deux
ans avec la pandémie
faire revenir des français qui étaient à
l'étranger n'y parvenait pas à revenir
ils sont et des centaines de milliers
vous le savez leur fournir des vaccins
lorsqu'ils n'en avaient pas
évacuer nos compatriotes d'afghanistan
les évacués d'ukraine plus récemment et
donc je veux vous vous remercier
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qui avaient fait
ce rapport
vous avez
parfaitement dit que servir cette maison
c'est à voir l'engagement d'une vie
les agents du ministère ils sont très
sensibles
je le suis aussi alors dans ce contexte
qui ne tient pas qu'à une réforme mais
qui tient à cette prise en tenaille
désormais entre nos moyens et et nos
missions il m'est apparu fondamental de
réagir y compris à mon niveau donc j'ai
écouté tout de suite les agents
et renouer le dialogue je poursuivrai je
me suis entretenu avec les organisations
syndicales bien évidemment elles sont
représentatives mais aussi avec les
représentants des grévistes je les ai
reçus dès le 7 juin noko lendemain de la
grève mais j'ai aussi profité de la
tenue du comité technique ministériel du
1er semestre pour poursuivre le dialogue
et la concertation
le 21 juin
et ce dialogue si on veut qu'il
fonctionne il faut le poursuivre en
travaillant dans trois directions
mettre en oeuvre la réforme de la haute
fonction publique au quai d'orsay ce une
réforme de la haute fonction publique
qui a été fait et qui ne singularise par
le quai d'orsay
notre maison pense à elle c'est bien
normal mais elle n'est pas singularisé
je me suis employé à le lui dire il faut
donc expliquer mieux
expliquer mieux la réforme explique
aussi ce qu'elle représente
d'opportunités car c'est le cas il y a
également des opportunités pour les
agents et expliquer mieux détailler
mieux les garanties qu'ils ont été
obtenus par mon prédécesseur jean yves
le drian sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui sont des sujets importants
structurant pour notre diplomatie les
concours les carrières le droit d'option
le pouvoir de nomination
souvent ces garanties sont un peu
passées sous silence ou ne sont pas
appréciés à hauteur de ce qu'elle
représente parce qu'aucun autre
ministère n'a obtenu de telles garanties
et il y a eu pour tout vous dire
monsieur le président mesdames des
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
également quelques contre vérités
la mise en extinction des deux corps des
ministres et de conseiller des affaires
étrangères ne signifie pas l'extinction
des métiers et ne signifie pas
l'extinction des carrières nous avons
obtenu au contraire jean yves le drian a
obtenu que les agents qui servent ce
ministère puisse continuer d'y exercer
leur carrière tout le temps s'ils le
souhaitent nous avons aussi
maintenu le concours d'orient il sera
donc possible et c'était nécessaire de
recruter des spécialistes de zones
sensibles j'ai évoqué quelques uns des
dossiers qui nous occupe et qui trouble
la vie internationale on voit bien que
ces spécialités reste tout à fait
indispensable et puis
d'une façon générale avoir des
compétences multiples avoir des agents
aux talents divers ça fait partie de ce
qui fait la force de notre diplomatie
vous avez bien voulu me rappeler le le
président qu'elle était une des
meilleures au monde la deuxième
direction
et nous allons avoir notre discussion
budgétaire bientôt c'est qu'il faut
réarmer ce ministère en termes
budgétaires et surtout en termes
d'emploi l'enjeu est capital on pourra
citer des tas de chiffres dans nos
conversations avec le mystère du budget
avec un certain nombre de nos collègues
avec la première ministre ou même
parfois que le président de la
république chacun peut trouver des
chiffres à l'appui de sa démonstration
mais je ne retiendrais qu'un en 15 ans
et à périmètre constant
c'est important parce que les évolutions
de périmètre dans le passé peuvent
conduire à des effets d'optique fashion
à périmètre constant ce ministère a
perdu plus de 10 8 % de ses effectifs
alors que les effectifs de l'état resté
globalement stable
-1 18% de ses effectifs comment les
agents de mon ministère pourrait-il
assurer des fonctions plus nombreuses
plus importante plus critique souvent
avec tant de personnel en moins
ils l'ont fait et encore une fois il
faut leur rendre hommage parce que nous
avons assurer ce service y compris dans
les crises et chaque fois qu'il le
fallait vous voyez que le comportement
des diplomates est exemplaire et des
agents même lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
diplomates sont exemplaires
mais d'autres ministères n'ont pas fait
cet effort d'autres même et je voudrais
rappeler que nous sommes un mystère dits
régaliens je prends des points de
comparaison avec les ministères
régaliens ont vu leurs moyens et leurs
effectifs augmenter les armes et l'ont
fait et c'était nécessaire la justice
l'a fait et c'était nécessaire la dgse
l'a fait et c'était nécessaire pour
trouver d'autres exemples nous avons ces
années après années des efforts tels que
ça nous amène aujourd'hui à la situation
vous avez souligné à la situation qui
l'objet d'autres rapports et qu'il faut
dépasser en sortant par le haut comme on
dit en suivant les trois directions que
je recommande celle ci était la deuxième
elle est importante et j'espère que dans
la discussion budgétaire qui s'annonce
je pourrai compter sur la bienveillance
et même sur l'appui de la représentation
allemand
une nouvelle crise pendant s'ouvre
troisième direction merci beaucoup mais
mignonne vous en avez entendu parler
puisque vous êtes en contact avec les
agents de notre mystère et en
particulier avec les agents qui ont fait
grève qui se sont exprimés
les assises où les états généraux de la
diplomatie c'est une idée que j'ai fait
mienne qu'il faut maintenant que nous
mettions en oeuvre parce qu'il faut
réfléchir au delà de
la technique la consolidation des
garanties au delà des questions de
budget d'emploi il faut réfléchir à
l'outil diplomatique dont la france et
les français ont besoin dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui le dernier livre blanc
remonte à 2008 je me souviens d'avoir eu
l'honneur de participer au travail qui a
été fait par le ministère sous l'égide
d'alain juppé de louis schweitzer 2008
c'est déjà un peu loin derrière nous le
monde a beaucoup changé et pour tout
tient il ne s'est pas simplifié et je
pense que cet exercice non seulement
serait nécessaire compte tenu du malaise
qui s'est exprimée le de jeu ou même
avant le 2 juin et traduit par cette
grève du 2 juin mais il est
indispensable et salutaire il est
nécessaire pour nous tous je voudrais
vous dire que nous aurons dans cet
exercice besoin de votre regard besoin
de votre approche et donc je serais
heureuse de vous consulter de vous
associer à ce travail de fond si vous
souhaitez vous même être partie prenante
sur le point particulier
des dunes des propositions que vous avez
fait est que vous avez évoqué en
introduction monsieur le président tout
en précisant que je n'ai pas pu encore
prendre connaissance aujourd'hui de
votre rapport qui est celui
d'un avis que donnerait ou que pourrait
donner les commissions des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées pour ce qui concerne le sénat des
deux assemblées sur les nominations
d'ambassadeurs
je prends note de votre proposition je
vous en remercie elle posera avant même
toute réflexion sur une question
d'opportunité elle posera une question
de faisabilité juridique j'aurai donc
besoin de l'expertisé dans le détail et
je me propose de revenir vers vaut bien
évidemment compter sur moi je le ferai
voilà mesdames les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le président je veux
saluer la contribution qui est la vôtre
au travail diplomatique de la france une
contribution toujours amicales exigeante
vigilante comme et se doit je compte
bien poursuivre
en confiance ce travail avec vous merci
de surprise non merci madame la ministre
merci de ces premières analyses à la
fois sur la situation internationale et
en réponse au travail que nous venons de
faire sur le corps diplomatique
vous l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises
notre volonté et je pense que c'est
évidemment la vôtre c'est de vous donner
bien évidemment les moyens d'assumer les
missions qui vous sont confiées
sans plus attendre ce que génisses très
impressionnante de le coller qui veulent
intervenir donc j'ai déjà donné à
parlant andré vallini et qui est
rapporté ce blanc puis après on va
essayer de concentrer un peu nos pensées
de ne pas lui nous nous prenons les noms
nous prenons les noms aller allons-y
andré merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous êtes une diplomate
chevronné vous avez servi dans des
postes prestigieux rome à londres vous
avez été déjà au gouvernement chargé des
affaires européennes et vous savez mieux
que quiconque que la voix de la france
est attendu sur la scène internationale
que son rôle n'est pas n'importe quel
rôle et que pour jouer ce rôle la france
a besoin de diplomates professionnels
aguerris expérimentés
j'ajoute et vous l'avez laissé entendre
d'ailleurs qu'être diplomate correspond
souvent à une vocation qu'on a ces
jeunes dès l'adolescence et je suis
frappé mois depuis je m'occupe
d'affaires internationales comme mes
collègues de voir à quel point les
diplomates aiment leur métier qu'ils
n'ont jamais envisagé d'en faire un
autre alors à partir de là vous l'avez
dit vous-même cette réforme n'est pas
comprise elle est même rejeté par les
personnels du quai d'orsay
on avance parfois l'argument pour
défendre la réforme qu'elle serait
nécessaire pour ouvrir le corps pour
sortir de l'entretoit au rejet des
chiffres qui montrent qu' il n'ya pas
d'entre eux soit que le corps est déjà
ouvert 20% de l'encadrement n'est pas
issu du corps diplomatique au quai
d'orsay et en 2019 19 % des enfants
ambassadeurs étaient occupés par des
personnes en détachement ou intégrés au
mae
donc cette réforme est inutile pour
sortir de l'entretoit il n'existe pas et
puis surtout elle est dangereuse de
prison cambon l'a dit tout à l'heure les
crises se succèdent
il ya la guerre en ukraine les défis
migratoires climatiques économiques sont
nombreux et face à tous ces défis nous
avons besoin d'une véritable diplomatie
professionnels or avec la réforme dont
nous parlons qui peut garantir que
demain près faits même si c'est un très
bon préfet ou un sous préfet ou un haut
fonctionnaire de bercy aux affaires
sociales sera à même d'être un bon
ambassadeur personne ne peut garantir et
tout le monde peut même en douter voilà
pourquoi madame la ministre dans notre
rapport nous présentons des suggestions
d'amendements de la réforme etc avant
tout nous souhaitons qu'elle soit
suspendue le temps d'organiser les états
généraux dont vous avez parlé
rendre
bloc un certain nombre de questions tout
de suite bruno sido
merci monsieur efforts les uns les
autres d'être assez concentré parce qu'
une page entière de demande
d'intervention
allons-y merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre l'année 2022 est
fortement sollicité l'administration
consulaire en charge de l'organisation
des élections présidentielles
d'initiative soit quatre tours de
scrutin dans un contexte géopolitique et
sanitaires difficiles
je pense qu'on confinement très strictes
imposées par les autorités chinoises qui
ont rendu impossible la participation de
nos compatriotes de shanghai à
l'élection présidentielle
j'en profite pour saluer la mobilisation
de l'ensemble des agents de nos postes
consulaires et diplomatiques
les élections législatives n'ont pas
posé le même type de difficulté pour les
électeurs puisque ceux ci pouvaient
participer au scrutin à distance au
moyen d'une procédure de vote
électronique toutefois la presse comme
certains de nos compatriotes ont
rapporté certains dysfonctionnements à
ma demande conjointe est insistante
madame la ministre avec mon collègue
rapporteur pour avis guillaume comptes
dont tard votre cabinet a bien voulu me
transmettre hier seulement après quinze
jours de demande même quasiment un mois
un bilan d'organisations de votre vote
électronique pour le premier tour qui
s'est tendu tenue le 27 mai 2000 22 au
mercredi 1er juin 2022 et pour le second
tour du 10 juin au 15 juin 2022 il est
intéressant de relever que sur 1,4
million d'inscrits sur les listes
électorales consulaires le vote par
internet a représenté plus de 75% des
votants avec 250 1566 vote au premier
tour et 273 1927 au second tour je mets
je remercie à ce stade la direction de
l'administration des français l'étranger
pour ce premier travail d' analyse que
je prévois d'approfondir pour mieux
chiffrer l'impact des problèmes
techniques rencontrés on a parlé de
difficultés de réception des sms ou les
courriels d'envoi des identifiants et
des mots de passe mais aussi d'une
coupure pendant plusieurs heures du
portail de votre ministère madame la
ministre qu'il s'agisse de la
possibilité de se déplacer pour des
élections présidentielles ou des
dysfonctionnements de votre lectrice
pour les législatives combien d'inscrits
sur les listes électorales consulaires
ne se seraient vu empêcher de voter
quelles sont les pistes d'amélioration
du scrutin électronique sans pour autant
supprimer la tenue des bureaux de vote
physique proposeriez-vous d'élargir la
possibilité de voter par internet aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
merci jean marc todeschini
ainsi monsieur le président madame la
ministre merci pour votre aux propos
liminaire donc j'éviterais de revenir
sur certains certains points mais vous
avez évoqué votre déplacement en afrique
il était nécessaire d'aller d'y aller
assez rapidement vous y est allé avec le
ministre des armées est ce que vous
pourriez nous décrire
actuellement les relations réelles avec
le gouvernement malien est en capacité
et en capacité d'assurer
un jeu très de loin
parce qu'ils sont prêts c'est en
capacité d'assurer le retrait je poserai
la question bien sûr à votre collègue
lendemain d'assurer le retrait de nos
troupes
la fermeture de la base de gao vous avez
dit ensuite vous même qu' il s'agissait
de reconstruire toute la stratégie du
président de la république pays par pays
lui-même l'a dit que la stratégie devait
être complètement repensé pouvez vous
nous dire pourquoi en dehors de relation
avec de malice et bien compris que la
france basée aujourd'hui
j'irai sur ceux basés sur le niger et
puis la base au tchad qui est absolument
nécessaire pour pour nos armées mais en
quoi cette stratégie d'hôtel à être
pensée existe et elle ou ne vous était
telle mauvaise je pense qu'on pourrait
vous pourriez peut-être de faire le
bilan sur le sujet là et y at il une
stratégie européenne sur cette bande
sahélo-saharienne puisieux on nous avait
beaucoup parlé la ministre des armées
précédentes nous parlait beaucoup de la
force takouba on a vu que le takouba
s'est dissous tout cela disparaît enfin
sur l'ukraine les images aujourd'hui de
la population française peut voir peut
voir huys et amène à penser que c'est
tout tourne al'avantage de l'armée russe
actuellement ce n'est pas le cas mais je
souhaite en tout cas vous évoquez les
fournitures française tout en disant ne
pas les détails et c'est la position de
la france depuis un certain temps on
nous parle comme des cales des canons
caesar jusqu'au nombre qu'il resterait
finalement puisque c'est facile à
décompter les canons qui reste à la
disposition de nos de nos propres armes
alors quels sont les engagements
renouvelés de la france existe et il l'a
aussi une véritable approche européenne
car si on a pu éprouver la solidarité de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne finalement chaque pays a
souhaité développer lui-même sa propre
relation avec l'ukraine ce qui donne un
peu l'impression que l'union européenne
ait quelque chose en plus à côté des
des pays membres et non pas le canal
principal merci merci jean marc marié
arlette carlotti merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre les
militaires nous ont dit ici à plusieurs
reprises que l'armée seule ne pourrait
pas régler le problème au sahel la
stratégie était basée sur trois piliers
la diplomatie la défense et le
développement
et il semble que c'est le volet
développement le pilier développement
qui de mon point de vue n'a pas été
suffisamment appuyée au mali nous
n'avons pas consolider l'état de droit
nous n'avons pas su nous avons pas pu et
particulièrement chauffe qu'on était
très en réserve sur la zone des trois
frontières qui pourtant était une de nos
priorités nous sommes prioritaires dans
le cadre de l'aide publique au
développement alors du coup au niger mme
désormais il faut répondre à cet
impératif si on ne veut pas déstabiliser
le président bazoum vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé de ses
inquiétudes pour répondre
particulièrement à sa demande concernant
l'éducation c'est son objectif c'est ce
qu'ils réclament et donc il faut
vraiment un équilibre entre
effectivement l'implication militaire et
en faisant attention au risque
d'effacement de la présence militaire
dans cette zone mais aussi de l'autre
côté de l'aide au développement ma
question la première madame la ministre
comment faire justement pour que l'échec
de la stratégie 3d enfin je l'appelle
l'échec mais en tout cas la défaillance
du pilier développement ne se reproduise
pas quel équilibre vous pouvez trouver
et une question subsidiaire cet
équilibre passe également par la
garantie pour les organisations de la
société civile de pouvoir assumer cette
aide est notamment dans le cadre de
l'urgence humanitaire sans appliquer une
quinqua contre cris criblage nous avons
adressé un courrier à votre prédécesseur
sur la question du criblage nous n'avons
pas eu de réponse et nous attendons de
votre part une réponse également sur ce
point
merci guillaume gontard oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
d'abord je prie de bien vouloir
m'excuser parce que je risque de
m'absenter à 18 heures pour la
conférence des présidents dont je vais
peut-être pas là pour la pour la réponse
vous avez répondu à beaucoup de beaucoup
de choses moi j'avais une question très
précise ou plutôt une alerte notamment
sur le financement par l'afd d'un projet
industriel
polluant et dangereux au parc national
de kahuzi biega au congo et selon
plusieurs informations de rfi l'afd a
récemment décidé de soutenir
financièrement le parc national protégé
de kahuzi biega donc en république
démocratique du congo pays en proie à
une guerre civile meurtrière et le
projet soutenu par des investissements
occidentaux et notamment l'allemagne
prend place dans une région où les
exactions contre la population sont
fréquentes plusieurs rapports des ong
qui font part de deux meurtres de viols
et d accès d'exactions à c'est assez
terrible et elle montre également que
les bailleurs de fonds les ong de
conservation présentes sur place
auraient connaissance de ces faits à la
demande des pouvoirs publics allemands
une commission denquête soi disant
indépendante a été diligentée
jazeera par exemple a mis en lumière de
graves dysfonctionnements dans cette
commission et son absence d'indépendance
puisque le gestionnaire du parc en
faisait en faisait partie et puis l ong
survival international rfi détiennent
également des éléments qui impliquerait
indirectement la fdc quelque chose de
particulièrement particulièrement grave
et je dirais quoi qu'il en soit cette
participation de l'afd à cette
expropriation des populations
autochtones bats toi nous semble entrer
en contradiction avec la loi du 4 août
2000 21 de programmation relative aux
bleus développement solidaire et la
lutte contre les inégalités mondiales
qu'on a promulguée l'an dernier et
notamment sur une proposition de notre
part aspiré des ong le rapport annexé à
la loi précise que la france exercent
une vigilance particulière sur les
projets menés dans les territoires où
vivent les personnes appartenant aux
populations autochtones donc voilà ma
miss vous et vous avez déjà alerté par
par écrit et donc je vous alerte à
nouveau pour savoir si vous allez
intervenir pour que l'afd ne participe
pas à ce désastre écologique merci merci
alors on va terminer ce groupe e avec
cédric perrin
merci me suis présent dans la ministre
quelques mots sur l'otan
le nouveau concept stratégique de l'otan
prend soin de ne pas qualifier la chine
de menaces est ce qu'on doit y voir la
patte française à nos alliés ont souvent
notamment à l'assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan des positions beaucoup plus
tranché que la nôtre sur cette question
est ce qu'on ne risque pas en martelant
cette troisième voie française
on à de pacifiques sur un certain
isolement stratégie caucus en étant une
illustration assez criante fait que nous
ne l'ayons pas vu venir nous a quand
même alerté sur la question est ce que
les positions françaises sont réalistes
dans ce domaine dans la zone indo
pacifique est ce que madame le ministre
nous avons les moyens de nos ambitions
on est en train de commettre un rapport
sur la question à la commission et cette
question évidemment est criante et puis
un point particulier sur ce qui se passe
en ce moment à téhéran entre erdogan
raïssi et poutine on ne l'a pas évoqué
la question mais ces trois présidents
qui défie régulièrement les démocraties
occidentales rendez vous aujourd'hui
pour un sommet international dont on
n'attend pas grand chose mais que
peut-on en pensez merci beaucoup voilà
je vous donne ma parole mais me faites
péter des réponses assez concise on va
pas de on va pas balayer l'ensemble du
monde en une soirée
redonnez nous quelques principes et puis
on aura l'occasion de revenir sur les
sujets qui ont été évoqués allons-y
merci monsieur le président je
m'efforcerai d'être consiste un peu
moins lapidaire que je l'étais en
interrompant le synthé leur taux de
skinny je lui demande de me pardonner
monsieur sénateurs vallini vous avez
volé souligné que la photo la voix de la
france est attendu je le crois aussi
merci également d'avoir souligné que le
ministère des affaires étrangères est un
ministère ouvert il est peut être plus
que d'autres je crois qu'il est bon que
ça se sache pour ma part j'ai voulu
peut-être vous souvenez-vous souligné
que dans la réforme il y avait également
des opportunités en termes plus
administratif je veux bien qu'il y a des
mobilités en 30 mai qu'il aussi des
mobilités sortante qui n'est pas le
point fort que nous avons jusqu'ici
développé dans la culture de notre
ministère
la réforme permettra en réalité de
renforcer cette mobilité elle permettra
aux diplomates
et j'y serai attentif d'aller également
ailleurs et donc de rayonner de porter
un certain nombre de valeurs et de
donner peut-être plus de poids au
ministère vers tod progert dans
l'interministériel nous ne le faisons
pas assez nous sommes souvent
accueillant pour les collègues nous
avons besoin de leur talent de leurs
compétences mais nous n'allons pas
suffisamment rayonner à l'extérieur de
ce ministère aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas à cette diplomate dans les
préfectures ou dans les rectorats grec
quelques-uns avec les conseillers
diplomatiques des préfets et préfets de
région il n'a trop peu il y en a trop
peu dans les rectorats alors que j'ai
quelques j'avais je ne suis plus
diplomate quelques excellents collègues
d'ambassadeurs qui sont des réacteurs
deux d'entre eux en autriche et dans un
pays voisin donc il ya beaucoup
d'admiration qui sont trop fermé la
nôtre est ouverte elle doit bénéficier
grâce à cette réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui ne touche pas que
le quai d'orsay est loin de là d'un
certain de mobilité sortante et puis au
bout du bout que vous dire c'est
l'excellence des diplomates qui fera la
différence s'ils sont bons et sont
capables de le démontrer à l'extérieur
moi je ne suis pas inquiète dans leur
capacité à être accueillis ailleurs en
tout cas c'est une opportunité nouvelle
permise par la réforme qui n'existaient
pas précédemment le pouvoir de
nomination du chef de l'état nuit n'a
pas n'a pas été modifié et donc le cas
de figure que vous évoquez a toujours
été possible il le reste il sera pour ce
qui concerne des agents diplomatiques de
moindre rang que le rang d'ambassadeur
encadré désormais davantage qu'il ne
l'est puisqu'il fera passer par ce
processus de d'un panel et de
vérification des compétences dernier
point le sénateur vous avez évoqué comme
les grévistes le font parfois la
suspension de cette réforme je vais être
honnête avec vous comme je les ai été
avec eux il ne saurait y avoir de
suspension de la réforme puisque la
réforme est achevée elle repose sur une
ordonnance et des décrets dont le décret
qui a fait beaucoup parler de lui qui
est celui du 16 avril c'est un paradoxe
d'ailleurs qu'il y fait parler autant de
lui en termes négatifs alors que c'est
lui qui inscrit dans notre ordre
réglementaire les garanties qu'ils ont
été obtenus par jean yves le drian
monsieur le sénateur sido sur le vote
des étrangers
des français pardon à l'étranger il y a
eu des difficultés en chine c'est vrai
je m'en suis entretenu moi même avec mon
homologue chinois lors du premier
entretien que j'ai eue avec lui depuis
la situation s'est un tout petit peu
détendu mais il était anormal que nos
compatriotes ne puisse pas exercer leur
droit démocratique de vote je le lui dis
de la façon la plus claire pour le reste
nous avons une appréciation positive du
vote par internet le bilan est très
positif
non seulement aux yeux de la ministre
mais aux yeux des français qui en ont
bénéficié puisque nous avons eu notre
moyenne de 8,9 sur 10 lorsque nous avons
consulté nos compatriotes sur ce qu'il
pensait de ce dispositif qui était
nouveau alors qu'elle connut quelques
quelques heures jeudi de quelques heures
plus tôt que quelques ratés parce que
personne nous pratiquement personne n'a
été empêché de voter les quelques
incidents techniques
maintenant la coupure de réseau a été
réparée au bout de quelques heures ne
s'est pas reproduite pour le second tour
nous n'avons eu aucun incident technique
ce qui est assez remarquable pour une
première c'était une première et puis
positif aussi par le résultat qui l'a
permis vous avez bien voulu le rappeler
monsieur le sénateur les trois quarts et
même plus des trois quarts des suffrages
qui sont qui se sont exprimés grâce
parler français et d'étrangers ont été
réalisés grâce à ce vote électronique
donc bilan positif ce qui me permet de
répondre à votre dernière question oui
nous songeons il faudra vérifier si
toutes les conditions techniques sont
réunis mais nous songeons à développer
le vote par internet pour les différents
scrutins pour les français de l'étranger
monsieur sénateurs que des skinny vous
avez parlé de l'afrique et de l'ukraine
sur
l'afrique la situation
n'était pas mauvaise mais la situation a
évolué lorsque nous sommes intervenus en
2013 je lisais brièvement dans mon
propos liminaire nous sommes intervenus
à la demande du mali nous avons endigué
la progression terroriste ça ne fait
aucun doute la situation a évolué il y a
eu un double coup d'état il y a
désormais une
junte qui sont fermes sur elle même et
qui ne doit sa survie
qu'à la présence de mercenaires
étrangers qui par ailleurs se manifeste
plus par les exactions qu'ils commettent
que par leur talent à lutter contre les
groupes terroristes armés
il faut donc ré articulé c'était
indispensable dès lors que les autorités
fut-elle des autorités de fait
considérer que nous n'étions plus
bienvenu au mali je tiens à ajouter je
les dis de façon trop laconique tout à
l'heure que l'articulation du dispositif
français au mali se passe bien et pour
qu'il se passe bien il faut qu'elles se
passent en coordination avec les forces
armées maliennes donc dans cette
manoeuvre de repli les choses se passent
bien où tu nous le calendrier nous
espérons pouvoir finir avant la fin de
l'été en revanche sur le plan politique
très clairement un joli hameau nos
relations sont particulièrement limitées
avec la junte malienne est nécessaire
qu'il en soit ainsi vous avez parlé de
l'ukraine
nous avons
non seulement livré des césar qui font
la preuve de leur efficacité
jour après jour si vous le voyez sur les
réseaux sociaux qu utilise beaucoup les
autorités militaires ukrainienne mais
nous avons livré depuis le début des
équipements de protection nous allons
livrer des véhicules de l'avant blindé
permettant aux combattants ukrainien
d'aller au devant un plus plus plus en
sécurité nous livrons des munitions je
ne détaillerai pas ce qui a été fait
parce qu'il ne m'appartient pas de le
faire mais je vous rassure et ça n'est
évidemment pas uniquement la fourniture
des canons caesar 255 quels que soient
leur efficacité qui constitue l'axé
principal de notre effort nous livrons
des munitions parce que toutes les
munitions sentir et il faut les
remplacer et je voudrais vous rassurer
également il y à un processus de
coordination entre européens et d'une
façon générale entre alliés dans un
format qui est qui qui prend le nom de
rammstein parce que ça se déroule sur
cette base de ramstein même si ça n'est
pas l'otan qui coordonne mais les alliés
et européens qui se coordonnent entre
eux chacun fait ce sénateur à la hauteur
non seulement des demandes qu'il reçoit
et nous recevons régulièrement des
demandes très précises de la part des
autorités ukrainiennes mais il à hauteur
de ses capacités et de façon coordonnée
madame la sénatrice carlotti vous avez
parlé du mali du niger essentiellement
en regrettant que le pilier
développement n'est pas
était suffisamment développées ou
suffisamment efficace au mali
c'est vrai mais encore une fois il ya
une situation à laquelle nous avons dû
faire face ce n'est pas nous qui avons
c'est un un coup d'état ni un double
coup d'état qui a fait que les efforts
qu'il aurait fallu faire et qu'il aurait
fallu que les autorités de ce pays fasse
elle même avec notre aide n'ont pas été
fait ce qui conduit à la situation
actuelle
l'éducation reste pour nous une priorité
l'éducation des jeunes filles
prioritairement l'aide alimentaire nous
avons pu signer un certain nombre
d'accord là dessus au niger donc c'est
ceci qui va constituer la nouvelle
politique africaine de la france en
complément des accords de sécurité de
défense lorsqu'il y en aura
vous avez parlé du criblage et je veux
vous répondre très vite un travail
énorme a été fait à votre demande et sur
le fondement de la loi du 4 août 2000 21
travail guidé par une seule volonté qui
est de faciliter le travail des ong pour
réduire le plus possible les obligations
de criblage des bénéficiaires finaux il
sera poursuivi
j'ai noté une question aussi sur le parc
national en rdc de la part du sénateur
gontard le projet de soutien à ce parc
par l' agence française de développement
n'en était qu'au stade préliminaire
je suis informé de la situation
particulière dans cette zone j'ai donc
demandé que l'on regarde et j'ai demandé
pour vous répondre le plus précisément
de suspendre l'instruction de ce projet
qui en est fait soulève de réelles
questions voilà une réponse précise
j'espère monsieur sénateurs perrin enfin
vous ai parlé de la chine du concept
stratégique
de l'otan dans sa partie consacrée la
chine nous ne sommes pas isolés puisque
au contraire les 30 états membres de
l'otan ont trouvé une façon de traiter
des défis posés par la chine qui sont
nombreux qui ne sont pas que d'ordre
militaire de façon équilibrée donc nous
n'étions pas seuls à demander et obtenir
que dans le concept stratégique de
l'otan les défis que représente la chine
soit évoquée comme il convient la chine
est un partenaire et concurrent est un
compétiteur
pour ce qui concerne l'alliance
atlantique dans le champ géographique
doit être celui des questions de
sécurité liées à l'espace euro
atlantique la chine ne doit pas être
abordé en tant que tel mais dans la
mesure et dans la seule mesure où son
assertivité nouvelle est certain nombre
de positions qui sont les siennes
notamment dans l'inde au pacifique doit
être pris en compte pour la sécurité
euro atlantique
au-delà de ça et je ne reprendrai pas
docu ce d'autant que le
projet initié par l'ancien premier
ministre australien vivra sa vie mais on
le jugeront peut-être dans la durée et
il ne doit pas échappé que de nouvelles
autorités australiennes
et est issu des élections donc je n'en
parlerai pas spécifiquement sur l'un
d'eux pacifique notre position est
réaliste
je crois et elle correspond surtout aux
souhaits des pays de la région qui ne
veulent pas devoir choisir qui ne
veulent pas être laissée face à un seul
choix qui serait celui de la chine mais
pas non plus en situation de devoir
choisir entre la chine et autres il n'ya
pas de recherche loin s'en faut deux
logiques confrontation elle de bloc à
bloc donc nous ne voulons pas
l'encourager nous ne ne vont pas
l'encourager et nous devons être
présents être plus présent en effet par
nos territoires par nos populations par
les alliances que nous devons louer avec
nous et avec les pays de la région et y
compris je dois le dire et c'était
l'objet de longs entretiens entre le
président de la république et le premier
ministre albanais australien en
particulier avec notre partenaire
australien ne sommes pas naïfs nous
voyons parfaitement quel est le jeu de
la chine mais si nous voulons le
contrecarrer la plus mauvaise solution
serait d'entretenir logique de bloc à
bloc donc peut-être elle sortirait
gagnante donc ça n'est pas notre
stratégie
merci madame la ministre nous continuons
avec andré gattolin soyez concis je
voudrais chers collègues parce que
remercie monsieur le président madame la
ministre
il y à un point de choses sur cette
planète que nous n'avons pas évoqué qui
concerne peut-être pas directement la
france mais bien l'inde au pacifique
c'est le sri lanka à la crise économique
succède la crise politique et on le sait
aujourd'hui le sri lanka n'est pas
victime que de la corruption il est
victime d'une politique d'étranglement
par la dette de la part de la chine
comme on le voit dans d'autres pays
d'ailleurs plus proche du de l'asian
comme le cambodge ou laos où les niveaux
de dette deviennent assez insupportable
dans cette logique sinon de
confrontation mais en tous les cas de
conflictuelle était en indo pacifique
est ce que la france et d'autres pays
occidentaux sont prêts à poser la
question de ce risque de dette et donc
de domination
posée par pays tiers qui est celui de la
chine je vous remercie
merci yannick vaugrenard
merci président je vais revenir
rapidement sur sur le mali vous nous
avez dit madame la ministre il y avait
une feuille de route qui était envisagé
donc au niger
rappelons-nous qui du coup des tomes au
mali sans qu'une nous les voyons venir
or nos soldats aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
payé le prix du sang se retire avec un
risque majeur c'est que des attentats
soient commis au moment du retrait et
avec les conséquences mais sûr que cela
peut avoir
pensez vous que les moyens précédent et
actuel donné à la dgse au mali ont été
et sont suffisants
deuxième point s'agissant de la grande
bretagne
boris johnson a été remercié les
relations avec lui était très
tumultueuse
pensez vous que son retrait peut être
bénéfique dans le cadre des relations
franco britanniques notamment avec les
conséquences d'une meilleure application
tout comme plus honnête de ce qui avait
été décidé au moment du du break site
voilà simplement votre point de vue là
dessus
merci yannick olivier cadic c'est
monsieur le président madame la ministre
les membres du groupe union centriste se
ruent réjouit sincèrement de votre
nomination il nous vous souhaitons une
pleine réussite dans l'accomplissement
de l'accomplissement de votre mission la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui s'est achevé il y à trois
semaines a été remarquée et remarquable
nous voudrions saluer l'engagement de la
france et de l'union européenne en
faveur de l'ukraine et de son peuple
depuis le début de l'agression russe
vous avez mentionné l'adoption de
sanctions européennes
hier pour bloquer l'importation d'or en
provenance de russie depuis l'annexion
de la crimée par la russie en 2014 la
banque centrale de russie a plus que
doublé la part d'or dans ses réserves
elles sont passées de 8 9% à 21 7% cela
s'est fait au détriment de la part des
devises américaine et européenne dans le
même temps la russie a passé des accords
pour extraire de l'or au soudan en
république centrafricaine et au mali le
groupe wagner cdu sévit de manière
sinistre dans ces trois pays avez vous
prévu une action diplomatique pour
freiner l'activité russe en matière
minière avec ces trois pays madame
ministre vous avez une fine connaissance
du réseau diplomatique et consulaire et
connaissait ces défis vous le démontrer
encore par vos propos suite à la réforme
du corps diplomatique vous avez rappelé
la perte de plus de 18% des effectifs du
ministère en 15 ans l'exercice
budgétaire fait souvent apparaître le
mystère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères comme une simple structure de
coûts à maîtriser et à réduire on oublie
totalement les ressources engrangées
grâce à ses 2 tp un agent du service
vise a produit quatre fois plus de
revenus que son coût chacun de ces
agents fait gagner de l'argent à la
france à titre d'exemple parlons d'un
poste que vous connaissez parfaitement
londres 8 5 millions d'euros de revenus
en droits de chancellerie de visa en
2010 9 6 millions d'euros encaissés
depuis le début de l'année
les consulats ne doivent pas être vues
comme des structures de coûts mais
plutôt comme des structures de profits
qu'il convient de développer ils
fournissent un service public attendu
par nos ressortissants qui peine
actuellement obtenir des rendez-vous
pour avoir ou faire renouveler leur
passeport je partage votre avis sur
l'action bénéfique de votre prédécesseur
jean yves le drian qui a su mettre un
terme à l'érosion des moyens ces
dernières années mais l'heure est
peut-être venue de revoir l'ensemble du
dispositif pour recréer un nouvel élan
que pensez vous de l'idée d'une loi de
programmation consulaire afin de donner
une nouvelle perspective ce réseau
merci olivier un autre livier olivier
cigolotti
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez rappelé dans votre
propos introductif notre attachement à
la représentation de la france à
l'étranger sachez que nous avons été
également très attentif aux mouvements
de contestation de votre ministère qui
est loin d'être anodin nous serons tout
aussi attentifs aux états généraux aux
assises de la diplomatie que vous avez
également évoqué sans revenir sur
l'excellent rapport de nos collègues
vallini et et grands je souhaitais
prendre à part vous vous interrogez sur
le mouvement de nos diplomates nous
sommes au 15 juillet ce dernier est
pratiquement suspendu cela représente
environ 60 postes des familles ne savent
pas où elles iront des enfants ont
terminé leur leur année scolaire dans un
certain nombre d'établissements ne sont
pas sûrs d'y retourner nous sommes les
seuls à procéder de la sorte les états
unis l'allemagne l'italie et bien
d'autres pays européens nous regardent
souvent stupéfait nous expatrier ont
depuis des siècles des diplomates à
l'étranger dans nos différents postes
est ce que nous n'avons pas moyen de
faire mieux madame la ministre merci
merci olivier philippe folliot
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
sur les questions que les points que
vous avez abordés et notamment au niveau
de ce qui s'est passé avec locus
c'est malgré tout une violation
manifeste de l'article iv de l'alliance
atlantique
et
la france est certain nombre de d'autres
partenaires de l'alliance mais plus
particulièrement la france ont été un
peu humilié dans cette affaire
et je voudrais simplement
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
les réponses et les réactions qui ont
été les nôtres de nos cela même si une
nouvelle donne en australie aujourd'hui
ne doit pas nous empêcher de dire un
certain moment dans nos alliés notamment
américaines et britanniques
notre façon de penser notre façon
de considérer ce qui s'est passé par
rapport à cela mais ne pensez vous pas
aussi que si nous sommes arrivés à cette
situation notamment par rapport à nos
partenaires australiens
c'est parce que nous avons eu un déficit
dans notre stratégie indo pacifique
depuis un certain nombre d'années par le
biais de la non prise en compte de la
spécificité française qui est une
puissance non pas que européenne mais
présente dans la zone indo pacifique ne
serait ce qu'au travers de l'île de la
réunion de mayotte pour l'océan indien
et
de la nouvelle calédonie wallis et
futuna et de la polynésie donc pour pour
le pacifique et donc les éléments de
coopération régionale qui peut y avoir
au travers donc de nous outre mer est ce
que votre ministère les prendre
complètement en compte par rapport à
cela et notamment au travers des
différentes organisations de coopération
régionale merci philippe enfin hélène
conway mouret pour ce deuxième groupe
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je vous qu'est-ce que
questionnerait pas sur la réforme du
quai d'orsay on vous l'avait dit elle
est passée quand même par ordonnance le
décret a été publié le week-end de
pâques je pense qu'une meilleure
concertation aurait débouché sur un
contenu peut-être plus acceptables et
acceptées par tout le monde et ce n'est
pas non plus sur les français de
l'étranger puisque je crois que nous
aurons l'occasion lors du débat bugey
hier en effet de vous présenter des
amendements ce que nous faisons chaque
année non pas pour être désagréable avec
le gouvernement et pour montrer à chaque
fois que vraiment ce ministère
souffre terriblement depuis des années
en effet vous avez très bien décrit la
situation aujourd'hui et nous avons
besoin peut-être de plus de moyens ou
comme le dit mon collègue olivier cadic
d'une réflexion de fond à savoir en
effet quel sont les missions aujourd'hui
qu'ils reviennent ou diplomates et
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à augmenter
leur nombre tout en réduisant les moyens
financiers humains je voudrais
simplement vous poser une question sur
l'afrique pour revenir à votre
déplacement au niger avec votre collègue
ministre de la défense je crois que le
président du niger en effet fait preuve
d'une grande lucidité quant aux
problèmes sécuritaires de son pays n'est
pas le seul je crois que c'est toute
cette partie de l'afrique aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont souffrance et c'est vrai que
si en effet nous avons besoin d'une
politique 3d plus équilibrée en matière
de développement il me semble qu'il ya
un élément pernicieux auxquelles nous
devons répondre et je ne sais pas si
votre ministère en tout cas il en est
pas équipé aujourd'hui ne devraient pas
mener une réflexion et voir comment nous
pouvons répondre à la propagande anti
française celle ci aujourd'hui touche
par les réseaux sociaux une population
jeune à laquelle nous ne savons pas
répondre nous
n'avons pas nous ne nous sommes pas
équipés en tout cas les les ambassadeurs
ne le sont pas en poste
de pouvoir répondre rapidement et
utilement à celle ci et nous sommes
toujours en décalage donc je pense que
nous avons vraiment besoin aujourd'hui
de nous équiper peut-être y avez-vous
déjà réfléchi peut-être que le ministère
a une cellule en place que nous ne
connaissons pas mais il faut vraiment
agir sur ce plan là parce que je crois
que nous sommes en train de perdre une
grande partie de la population merci
merci hélène
je redonne la parole aux des
quelques réponses à ces questions
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur gâteau la vous
évoquer la situation au sri lanka en
soulignant la grave crise économique a
traversé ce pays et qui a conduit à une
situation politique que nous connaissons
c'est un pays qui est soumis depuis
depuis longtemps aux influences non
seulement de la chine mais de la chine
et de l'inde et ce qui a précipité de la
situation c'est que le pays s'est trouvé
en la capacité et d'honorer ses dettes
avec de surcroît est peut-être que
la guerre en ukraine ne peut avoir joué
son rôle également une aggravation des
difficultés de se procurer un certain
nombre de biens essentiels de
médicaments et de produits alimentaires
il est certain que
maintenant nous sommes dans une nouvelle
phase politique la question de la
soutenabilité des dettes reste posée il
faut souhaiter que ce pays soit moins
imprudent et ne se lit pas les mains des
partenaires étrangers qui proposent
des conditions forte attractive mais
dans les effets à plus long terme sont
particulièrement pénalisant
d'ici là et en parallèle il est
indispensable que le fmi
joue son rôle je ne vois pas de sortie
de crise possible sans un programme
d'assistance du fmi avec une
restructuration de la dette mais avec
aussi d'importantes réformes donc deux
partenaires devront s'accorder nous
devons les y encourager aussi bien le
fonds monétaire international que les
nouvelles autorités du sri lanka
mais se servir vaugrenard sur le royaume
uni
est ce que
le retrait de boris johnson non encore
effective bénéficiera nos relations
jean forme le voeu évidemment je veux
l'espérer il m'est même arrivé je crois
dans formé le voeu publiquement en
soulignant que ce serait nécessaire que
c'est possible parce que la situation
actuelle ne permet pas à nos pays
d'assumer leur rôle à la hauteur de ce
que doit être leur responsabilité dans
le monde est-ce que ce voeu sera exaucé
je ne saurais le dire puisque nous ne
sommes pour le moment que dans une phase
préparatoire à la succession de monsieur
johnson qui est la phase d'une campagne
électorale
menée au sein du parti conservateur avec
un premier temps
au sein des députés actuellement élu et
que ça se prête plus me semble-t-il à la
surenchère qu'à la construction de
meilleures relations avec l'union
européenne ou avec la france donc il
faudra attendre le second temps pour que
je puisse vous répondre mais center
cadic sur les
manoeuvres
russe pour
s'implanter plus durablement en afrique
nous les voyons nous les dénonçons je
crois que la france est l'un des pays
qui a été le plus clair à ce sujet y
compris pour éclairer peut-être un
certain nombre de nos partenaires voire
même voire même certains partenaires
africains pour que les sirènes ne chante
pas trop doucement à leurs oreilles pour
ce qui concerne
l'or je reviendrai vers vos parce que je
ne sais pas ce qui a été fait ou ce qui
peut être fait dans des circonstances où
les milices de wagner agissent comme des
prédateurs
sur la question de nos consulats
merci d'avoir souligné ce qu'a porté le
ministère je ne le vois pas comme une
structure de profits ne sommes pas
encore d'un secteur privé mais normand
il est bon de souligner que la
diplomatie ne coûte pas tout chaud
parfois même elle elle rapporte il en va
de même des consulats et puis nous
assurerons avant tout le service public
que nous devons assurer pour les
français qu'ils vivent à l'étranger où
qu'ils soient de passage alors une autre
programmation consultables pourquoi pas
nous verrons ce que donnent les états
généraux les réflexions que nous
mènerons cet automne donc je ne veux pas
préjuger de leur résultat je suis
ouverte à toute option on peut
regarder avec la tentation en tout cas
avec envie les lois de programmation qui
existent dans le domaine militaire qui
sont promises dans le domaine de la
justice
donc pourquoi pas en matière consulaires
et diplomatiques je crois que s'il
devait y en avoir il ne trouverait pas
la limiter au champ consulaires tout en
soulignant ce sénateur vous le savez que
dans leur terre qui a été pris par
nombre de nos ambassades et consulats
une partie est due au sous-effectif et
une partie du tout simplement à la
pandémie qui nous a conduit à réduire la
voilure pendant les moments de
confinement ils ont été nombreux et est
long pour ce qui concerne le royaume uni
monsieur sa terre vous avez posé la
question du du mouvement est observé à
juste titre que nous sommes d'ores et
déjà le
19 juillet
croyez bien que j'ai travaillé sans
relâche depuis le premier jour je dis
depuis le premier jour avec
début juin quelques nominations qui ont
pu qui ont pu passer et depuis parce que
ces nominations de pression en conseil
des ministres donc la pauvre non
seulement du gouvernement mais du
président de la république est
nécessaire du travail préparatoire qui a
été fait qu'il n'a pas encore pu aboutir
mais j'espère que demain si vous m'aviez
interrogé demain ma réponse aurait pu
être différente et peut-être est
peut-être la semaine sud ce serait bien
qu'on en prenne connaissance
on ne peut pas le faire donc que les
agréments n'ont pas été données par les
affaires des pays concernés j'espère que
demain il y aura une preuve de
l'accélération
mais cette interview je ne reviens pas
sur rochus parce que c'est moi l'article
4 du traité de l'atlantique nord qui
était en cause que le manquement à
l'obligation la plus élémentaire de
confiance entre partenaires qui traitent
de sujets importants dans un partenariat
de longue durée tout ceci engager nos
nos pays sur quarante ou cinquante ans
vous en souvenez donc le manquement
principal a été là vous avez entendu mon
prédécesseur vous avez entendu le
président de la république dénonce et je
crois dans les termes les plus clairs
notre notre déception est donc dire
comme vous le souhaitiez notre façon de
penser à notre partenaire australien de
l'époque au delà oui vous avez raison
nos territoires ultramarins sont
un élément important de la puissance de
la france dans la région nous avons des
territoires nous avons des hommes nous
avons une présence militaire également
nous avons la deuxième zone économique
exclusive au monde grâce à ses
territoires et je souhaite pendant que
j'exercerai ma mission que nous
articulons mieux
les enjeux qui concernent
mon collègue ministre de l'intérieur qui
est en charge également des autres
maires et les enjeux de la diplomatie il
ya un continuum évident qu'il faut
retrouver et donc notre présence dans
l'un d'eux pacifique puisqu'elle passe
par nos propres territoires en grande
partie et pas seulement par l'action
diplomatique de la france dans la région
il faut mieux les combinés on a commencé
de le faire un sens sans attendre
que je vienne au gouvernement puisque le
sommet
u12 pacifique qui s'est tenue sous
présidence française au début de l'année
a permis de faire mieux prendre
conscience qu'il ya là des enjeux qui
dépassent même les enjeux pour notre
pays madame louis moret merci également
de ce que vous avez dit comme olivier
cadic et comme d'autres sur la façon
dont nos agents assument leurs missions
et leurs missions croissante il faut une
réflexion de fond c'est tout à fait
certain sur non seulement l'adaptation
de l'émission et de nos moyens mais sur
la place de la diplomatie dans l'état
quelles sont les missions qu'on juge
prioritaire nous ne pouvons pas les
définir nous mêmes nos autorités
politiques au delà de ce ministère
devront également nous fixer une ligne
de conduite sur le
niger et au delà sur sur la sous région
en cas mendient en afrique
comment répondre à la propagande anti
française et la propagande anti
occidental qui est à l'oeuvre que l'on
voit évidemment dans tous ses effets
néfastes qui est une propagande d'autant
plus efficaces qu'elles impliquent peu
de monde coûte très peu cher passe
essentiellement par les réseaux sociaux
pas seulement pour un certain nombre de
radios aussi et pour y faire face nous
n'étions pas équipés
parce que ça n'est pas notre façon de
faire parce que nous sommes les pays
démocratiques parce que nous ne
pratiquons pas la falsification de
l'information d'une manipulation
mensongère d'autres que nous
une spécialité à ce titre mais c'est un
autre honneur de ne pas le faire
néanmoins il faut contrer cette
propagande et la contrer plus
efficacement que nous le faisons c'est
l'objet de réflexions qui ont déjà été
engagés au sein de son ministère que je
poursuivrai et avec là aussi besoin
de moyens dans les demandes
budgétaires qui ont été présentées par
le ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères en faire ses plus hautes
autorités il y à celle ci nous devons
avoir un minimum de moyens et compris de
moyens humains pour avoir un dispositif
de lutte contre la désinformation
au sein de notre ministère mais aussi
avec une dimension interministérielle
indispensable émissaires des armées sera
mis à contribution d'autres services
aussi monsieur certains gattolin je
m'aperçois que je n'ai pas répondu à
votre question sur les moyens d'être gs
eux mais vous me pardonnerez ça n'était
pas à moi à y répondre
allez on attaque le dernier groupe uc se
rit on est bref je serai prêt si le
président madame la ministre l'article 2
de la loi de programmation relative au
développement solidaire prévoyait un
rapport du gouvernement ou au parlement
sur la comptabilisation de la paix des
beaucoup de parlementaires et d'acteurs
de la société civile regrette en effet
que les montants d'apaiser soit peu
lisibles car il inclut par exemple est
entre autres les frais d'écolage où les
dépenses pour les refuges et qui ne
dépendent pas à proprement parler de la
politique de solidarité internationale
et qu'il faut c'est l'appréciation que
l'on peut en avoir les auteurs de
l'amendement à l'origine de ce rapport
voulait affirmer un besoin de davantage
de clarté or loin d'aller dans ce sens
et d'apporter de nouvelles propositions
le rapport déposé par le gouvernement se
contente de rappeler que la france
respecte pleinement les critères de l'
ocde ce qui est heureux et ce que nous
savions déjà nous considérons que la
question est précisément de réfléchir à
une évolution de ces critères et de
promouvoir une réforme au sein de l'
ocde d'autres pays ayant déjà commencé à
agir en ce sens madame la ministre nous
souhaiterions donc que le gouvernement
puisse évoluer sur ce sujet je vous
remercie merci hugues jacques le nay
allons-y
madame la ministre alors qu'il n'y a pas
encore un an les talibans entrée dans le
cac ball nous fêtons cette année le
centenaire de la coopération et l'amitié
franco afghane comme vous l'avez
vous même si bien dit le 17 derniers
juin dernier depuis cent ans la france
se tient résolument aux côtés du peuple
afghan
aussi ma question est la suivante quel
est l'avenir de la délégation
archéologique française en afghanistan
dont on connaît le travail énormes
effectués par les équipes qui se sont
succédé dans ce pays
si jacques une école duranton merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
merci pour vos propos liminaire vous
avez souligné donc que dans votre propos
liminaire l'importance politique de
l'adhésion de la suède et de la finlande
à l'otan donc cela va renforcer notre
sécurité collective et renforcer la
place des européens au sein de l'otan
donc la signature des protocoles
d'adhésion par les ambassadeurs des 30
pays membres donc a ouvert le 5 juillet
donc au siège de l'alliance atlantique à
bruxelles le processus de ratification
donc la signature des protocoles
d'adhésion accorde le statut de pays
invité à la suède et à la finlande mais
elles ne bénéficieront pas de la
protection de l'article 5 de la charte
de l'otan en cas d' attaques tant que
les et 30 états membres n'auront pas
ratifié donc leur adhésion donc quel
degré de protection l'europe peut-elle
d'ores et déjà assurée à la suède et à
la finlande sur le plan militaire en cas
d'agression donc sur leur territoire ou
à proximité immédiate donc le président
r douanes à nouveau menacé hier donc de
geler l'adhésion de ces deux pays s'ils
ne prennent pas part donc est la lutte
contre le terrorisme
il souhaite l'extradition donc de 3
contre 33 militants donc appartenant une
trotte 33 militants kurdes pardon
appartenant donc aux mouvements du pkk
pensez vous que la prise de position du
président turc donc sur l'accession de
la suède et de la finlande à l'otan
puisse constituer un ralentisseur à même
de différer lourdement ces deux
adhésions et enfin donc au sommet madrid
vous avez eu un entretien avec le
secrétaire général de l'onu de l'onu
donc cet entretien a permis de souligner
la force de l'engagement de la france au
sein de l'alliance atlantique dont le
rôle central est encore souligné par
l'agression donc de la russie contre le
cren vous avez mis en avant le
renforcement de la contribution
française à la posture de défense et de
dissuasion sur le orientale donc quelles
sont les prochaines étapes du
renforcement de la contribution
française à la posture de défense et de
dissuasion sur le front oriental je
remercie
merci nicole gisèle jourda merci
monsieur le progressant sur les sujets
affaires étrangères s'il vous plaît
car demain nous allons la défense mad
madame la ministre
merci donc des propos que vous avez
tenus d éclairage que nous avait donné
depuis on que cette audition bon je
souhaiterais vous faire préciser un
point que vous avez évoquées et sur
lequel on peut passer rapidement mais
qui à mon sens c'est un point
fondamental
vous avez dit donc aujourd'hui l'ukraine
et la moldavie avait statut de candidat
pour rentrer dans l'europe donc je
voudrais vous qu'avez-vous les
politiques de voisinage et de
partenariat oriental et surtout le pays
qui quasiment conjointement en tout cas
dans la foulée avait déposé sa demande
d'adhésion à savoir la géorgie
qui donc depuis 2014 et 2016 est en
contrat d'association avec l'union
européenne et qui compte tenu des deux
conflits gelés avec l'os et il a quasi
donc est quand même fort marri de
devoirs que sur ces trois demandes
d'adhésion
deux ont été retenus u ne l'a pas été
donc je souhaitais vous avez évoqué
madame la ministre la notion de
communauté politique européenne or la
géorgie par exemple d'apporter aussi au
conseil de l'europe alors est-ce que
quel gage peut-on donner parce que pour
suivre les questions de partenariat
oriental madame la ministre et
poursuivre les trois accords et ukraine
moldavie et géorgie au gré des aléas
politiques suivies par ces pays et des
alternances politiques il est évident
que aux yeux des contrats d'association
à la fois il ya des progressions mais il
ya aussi quelquefois des régressions et
je dois avouer que c'est pas totalement
lisible et compréhensible et je
souhaiterais donc à voir donc votre
point de vue sur cette question d'autant
plus que madame la présidente de géorgie
est une ancienne de vos concerts et elle
a donc en main donc ce pays ce qui n'est
pas compte tenu de la situation une
sinécure donc quelles sont les
perspectives et comment envisagez vous
les relations avec la géorgie
merci gisèle pierre laurent
bonjour madame la ministre de de très
brefs question la première à quel niveau
de priorité placez-vous aujourd'hui dans
la politique française la résolution de
la question palestinienne
nous étions en israël quelques jours les
dirigeants israéliens nous ont
clairement dit que ça ne faisait pas
partie de leurs priorités au plus partie
de leurs priorités
la visite de joe biden
confiant que les états unis sont alignés
sur les priorités des dirigeants
israéliens est ce que la france pense la
même chose ou la france envisage t elle
de prendre une initiative sur la
résolution de cette question
palestinienne
deuxième question sur la turquie
on parlera jeudi matin de l'adhésion à
l'otan j'ai une question précise
craignez-vous à court terme dans les
semaines ou les mois à venir une
nouvelle offensive turque dans le
nord-est de la syrie contre les forces
kurdes
elle le craignent le dénonce je me suis
moi même exprimé sur cette question
et quand vie si vous le craignez est ce
que la france va s'exprimer sur cette
question et à propos du nord-est de la
syrie le rapatriement des enfants
syriens et de leur mère qui a connu un
nouvel épisode il ya quelques semaines
est ce que c est ce que ce rapatriement
va se poursuivre d'ici la fin de l'été
merci pierre enfin joëlle
garriaud-maylam
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je ne
reviendrai pas sur la réforme du corps
diplomatique je voudrais simplement dire
que depuis 1988 que je suis élu des
français de grande bretagne et d'irlande
sénatrice depuis 2004 je n'ai jamais
douté une seconde je peux attester de
l'immense qualité du personnel
diplomatique
jamais il n'a manqué à la france et je
peux vous dire qu'il fait l'admiration
de tous les pays étrangers
je voulais par contre vous interroger
sur un problème de communication
pas seulement vis-à-vis des peuples
africains où elle est importante bien
sûr mais aussi au sein même de notre
alliance euro atlantique je dois dire
que j'ai été assez scandalisé ce matin
en découvrant dans le magazine pourtant
très respectable eulmis atlantique
une intervention une interview de
l'ancien premier ministre du danemark et
ancien secrétaire général de l'otan
anders fogh rasmussen qui attaquaient la
france en dix ans que la france n'avait
quasiment rien livré en ukraine et nous
comparons avec les autres pays disant
par exemple que l'allemagne avait fait
dix fois plus alors qu'il ne s'agit que
de promesses alors madame la ministre ce
type d'argument est assez lamentable
bien sûr nous savons nous n'avons pas pu
faire autant que les états unis par
exemple
bien sûr nous ne faisons pas de
promesses nous nous faisons nous avons
des actes mais je crois qu'il sera
important de rappeler à nos partenaires
qu'il faudrait un petit peu plus de
dignité et de solidarité et rappelait
aussi ce que nous faisons ce que nous
avons fait par exemple en afrique et
dernière petite chose aussi enfin petite
chose qui ne l'est pas est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire quelques mots
peut-être sur le protocole
nord-irlandais merci beaucoup madame
ministre voilà à la vénétie voulait bien
répondre à ce dernier 30 questions
cette audition merci monsieur le
président merci mesdames les sénatrices
spéciaux les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur souris sur l'aide publique au
développement
nous nous en tenons actuellement aux
critères du comité de l'aide au
développement de l' ocde en effet c'est
un sujet de comptabilisation mais ce
sont les normes internationales les plus
respectés et les plus respectables je me
permettrai de
rap et même que l'aide aux réfugiés et
si l'on parle
d'un certain nombre de cas passer ça
correspond bien à une exigence de
solidarité donc je ne crois pas qu'il
soit ni nécessaire ni utile de sortir
l'aide aux réfugiés des critères de
développement néanmoins vous avez raison
notre aide au développement doit être
transparente totalement transparence et
comptez sur moi pour y veiller monsieur
le sénateur sur monsieur stallone et je
crois sur l'afghanistan et l'avenir de
la délégation archéologique française en
afghanistan
vu la situation est depuis la chute de
cagoules et cabaud les la prise de
pouvoir par les talibans est ce que l'on
joint à l'oeuvre depuis
la fin poursuit comme elle le peut ses
missions mais les poursuit depuis la
france les équipes qui étaient à kaboul
reste active et nous n'abandonnerons pas
l'afghanistan mais nous ne pouvons pas
évidemment
à l'heure actuelle est sans doute que
les perspectives optimistes sont encore
loin devant nous
imaginez remettre des personnels
français dans une position exposée en
afghanistan tout en nous tenant
évidemment à ce que cette mission se
poursuivre dès que les conditions le
permettront sur place et qu'elle
continue à se poursuivre comme c'est le
cas actuellement depuis paris
monsieur sénateur ou madame la sénatrice
durant ton pardon je n'ai pas pris les
notes qu'il fallait oui sur l'adhésion
de la suède 1 à la sénatrice et de la
finlande à l'otan vous avez raison il
n'y a pas de protection au titre de
l'aide dans cette l'antique tant que le
processus de ratification n'est pas
achevé qu'y at il eh bien le prénom de
république l'a rappelé je vous le
rappelle également volontiers la clause
d'assistance mutuelle qui est à peu près
l'équivalent entre états membres de
l'union européenne
c'est le cas de la suède et c'est le cas
de la finlande donc le fameux article 42
7 que nous avons rappelé tout récemment
lorsqu'il s'est agi pour la suède et
pour la finlande avant madrid de faire
part de leur souhait de rejoindre
l'alliance atlantique dans cet
intervalle et bien il y à une protection
de ces deux pays par le canal de l'union
européenne et ses états membres votre
autre aux questions portaient sur les
attitudes
du président r douanes et des
difficultés qui pourrait être anticipé
dans la ratification par la turquie de
ces deux protocoles
d'abord
l'accord fait l'objet d'un texte écrit
donc il s'agira pas pour les uns pour
les autres de s'écarter de ce qui a été
convenu c'est une évidence mais je dois
le rappeler
néanmoins au delà de ça je suis
convaincu que pour avancer le meilleur
moyen
est de poursuivre les uns des autres non
ratification d'ores et déjà la moitié
des états membres je crois ont achevé
leur processus de ratification et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me 2 je me
permettrai
dès cette semaine et bientôt devant
l'assemblée nationale de vous rappeler
combien notre sécurité collective
gagnera à la présence dans l'alliance
atlantique de la suède et de la finlande
il gisait sur le flanc oriental qui
concerne davantage je crois ce président
mes collègues de la défense même si je
vous rappelle volontiers que la france
est présente sur le flanc oriental en
tant que nation cadre en roumanie et
qu'elle a décidé de renforcer
après le sommet de madrid et l'annoncé
sommet de madrid
le sa posture sur place elle est
présente également en estonie maintenu
notre dispositif elle contribue aussi à
la surveillance aérienne et maritime de
l'espace
considérer
une question était posée sur
[Musique]
la différence de traitement entre
l'ukraine et
la moldavie d'une part et la géorgie
d'autre part madame la sénatrice si la
géorgie a été traité de façon différente
c'est parce que il est résulté de
l'examen fait par la commission qui dont
nous avons suivi la vie mais qui a fait
son examen de ces candidatures selon les
critères habituels d'examen d'une
candidature la commission a conclu que
la situation de la géorgie aussi bien sa
situation sur le plan économique que sur
le plan des réformes que ceux de l'état
de droit encore est un tout habillé pour
sa présidente qui était non seulement
une collègue mais qui demeure une amie
si vous me permettez de le dire la
situation n'était pas la même que celle
de la moldavie et de l'ukraine et donc
ne permettait pas d'envisager maintenant
l'octroi du statut de candidat je veux
appeler votre attention madame la
sénatrice sur le fait qu'il ait eu
néanmoins un progrès important pour la
géorgie qui a été accompli au moment de
ce conseil européen des 23 et 24 juin
puisque désormais la perspective
européenne la perspective européenne est
reconnue à la géorgie ce qui n'était pas
le cas jusqu'ici
mais ce sénateur laurent vous avez parlé
de plusieurs questions qui ont trait au
proche orient en quelques mots parce que
on pourrait évidemment être
plus longs et plus détaillées sur ce
sujet important la question
palestinienne demeure au centre
évidemment des difficultés
tant que la solution à deux états ne
sera pas mise en oeuvre et il est
douteux que les tensions puisse
cc nous encourageons et nous accueillons
volontiers toutes ces entreprises de
normalisation qui sont qui sont en cours
depuis quelques temps maintenant qu'on
appelle les accords d'abraham ils sont
bienvenus pour autant ils ne permettent
pas de traiter la question de fond
qu'est la question palestinienne il faut
poursuivre le président de la république
l'a dit avec celui qui fume en
homologues mais qui est devenu premier
ministre par intérim monsieur derrière
la pid je lui avais dit moi-même lorsque
il était mon homologue il fait partie de
ceux en israël qui considère que la
solution à deux états est nécessaire
par ailleurs nous avons des contacts
étroits avec l'autorité palestinienne
je me suis entretenu la semaine dernière
avec mon homologue palestinien al malki
dans la perspective de la visite du
président abbas cette semaine demain à
paris pour regarder comment
restaurer un horizon politique celui qui
manque tellement en ce moment il ne peut
qu'alimenter des frustrations et des
incompréhensions d'un région
la visite du président biden
a eu des éléments évidemment positif je
veux les saluer comme nous l'avons fait
officiellement aussi bien pour l'aide
aux palestiniens puisque des avancées
ont été enregistrées avec une aide de
100 millions de dollars aux profils
jérusalem est et de 200 millions de
dollars pour l'inra c'est une bonne
chose la france elle même bien sûr
contribuer à l'inra des
éléments positifs aussi à saluer vers
une relation plus normale
entre l'israël et l'arabie saoudite suit
cette visite l'espace aérien saoudien
est rouvert mais il est certain je crois
que nous serons d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut poursuivre cette dynamique
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de marge de
progression qu'il faudrait en termes
clairs faire davantage et se fixer des
objectifs plus ambitieux je reviens la
nécessité d'une perspective politique
seul à même de régler le conflit israélo
palestinien est de faire baisser les
tensions qui sont en train de monter qui
nous préoccupe madame la sénatrice
garriaud maylam
merci des appréciations élogieuses que
vous avez bien voulu porter sur notre
ministère est sur le travail de ses
agents
sur les armes françaises en ukraine jeu
j'assume totalement bien évidemment la
politique qui est celle du gouvernement
français par opposition à d'autres que
vous connaissez comme moi et comme le
sénateur cadic vous penserez un pays en
particulier
qui consiste à faire plus khadir puis
faire donc nous ne disons pas tout ce
que nous faisons nous avons répondu
depuis le mois de février
à différentes demandes elles sont
nombreuses qui nous ont été présentées
par les autorités ukrainiennes nous le
faisons à la hauteur de nos capacités
il y à des tensions sur un terrain en
nombre de matériels des difficultés en
livrer trop mais nous faisons beaucoup
plus de choses que ces fameux canons
caesar
dont on parle et c'est
tout à fait volontiers que nous en
parlons nous mêmes mais il n'ya pas que
ça il n'est pas nécessaire de livrer
trop d'informations confidentielles à
l'autre belligérant je vous demande de
bien vouloir le comprendre enfin sur le
protocole nord-irlandais sujet dont nous
parlions parlait beaucoup la réaction
unanime des états membres de l'union
européenne et de la commission était
mesurée et fonder ce sont des
comportements qui sont inadmissibles
un état ami et démocratique ne peut pas
envisager de mesures unilatérales
violent ses propres engagements et
violent un traité international nous
l'avons dit publiquement je lui dis moi
même liste ross lorsqu'à n'est venu me
voir à paris il faudra le rappeler si
c'était nécessaire au prochain premier
ministre britannique
bien merci madame la ministre pour cette
première prise de contact qui étaient
importantes et merci pour la la
précision de de vos questions vous avez
pu constater à la fois la diversité des
questions
l'excellente connaissance de nombre de
nos collègues sur ces sujets précis et
et merci d'avoir noué ce dialogue qui se
poursuivra et qui s'approfondit race est
ce que nous souhaitons puisque tous les
sujets qui ont été abordés sont des
sujets compliqués qui n'ont pas de
solution immédiate mais enfin vous avez
tracé des perspectives
je retiens aussi le fait que nous
partageons ensemble avocat s'il a la
volonté de maintenir ce réarmement
budgétaire du quai d'orsay qui nous
paraît important on a assisté pour les
plus anciens d'entre nous a une langue
dégradation
parfois même camoufler et parfois
ouvertes du budget des affaires
étrangères et
nous combattons chaque année dans
l'exercice budgétaire qui nous est
soumis cette tendance car elle nous
sommes mortifère pour le rayonnement de
la france et donc nous vous
accompagnerons évidemment sur ce sur ce
point bon nous avons évoqué cette
difficulté qui existe entre notre
perception et celles du gouvernement
concernant la réforme du corps
diplomatique je vais pas revenir sur le
sujet je prends acte de la de la fin de
non recevoir sur la suspension de la
réforme c'était une main tendue
je pense que et quand les côtiers
réforme passe avec difficulté je pense
que parfois vous mieux me prendre un peu
de temps et puis faire en sorte d'en
parler nous nous restons la main tendue
et nous regarderont avec attention la
suite que vous souhaiterez donner à nos
propositions puisque on n'est pas dans
une position de blocage absolu même si
nous avons émis des voeux particuliers
mais
sincèrement je crois qu'il ya eu une
incompréhension au sein des deux
assemblées du reste car ne vous trompez
pas sur ce que pense le nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale avec qui j'ai
régulièrement l'occasion de m'entretenir
et je ne souhaiterais pas pour ma part
que ça ait des conséquences après les
votes des budgets terrain où il ya tout
le parlement lorsqu'il se sent un peu
mis de côté
peut avoir des réactions qui peut-être
un peu épidermique vous nous avez dit
que vous souhaitiez dans le cas des
états généraux nous associer c'est un
point important que je retiens aussi
positivement car toutes celles et ceux
qui sont rassemblés ici ont aussi une
expérience de diplomatie parlementaire
soit par les groupes d'amitié soir par
l'émission les rapports les uns les
autres voyage énormément rencontrer
diplomates et donc ils ont une idée
assez précise aussi de cette réalité
mais nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler voilà pourquoi madame est miss
merci donc à vous même votre équipe pour
la préparation de ses contacts je pense
qu'il faut rester dans la philosophie
que nous avions avec votre prédécesseur
d'un lien de confiance ce qui ne ce qui
n'empêche pas parfois les points de
désaccord et on les assume chacun dans
nos sensibilités mais j'ose croire à
vous avoir entendu que nous partageons
ensemble encore une fois cette même
volonté de le porter au plus haut le
rayonnement de la france qui en a bien
besoin il ya quand même beaucoup de
difficultés ne diplomatie la présence
française on n'a pas parlé ce soir mais
on en parlera sûrement de toute la
dimension éducative représente afp les
instituts français etc il ya beaucoup de
choses qui participe au rayonnement de
la france donc nous serons le rapporteur
sont toujours assez exigeant surtout
cela mais nous voulons le faire de
manière positive dans cet esprit
particulier du sénat qui vise à ne
jamais être dans le blocage mais dans
les propositions merci infiniment même
ministre